so the other night while we were live i
guess gavin mcginnis doing his show he's
the founder of the proud boys and uh uh
he runs censored.tv for those that
aren't familiar
he's doing his show and then he stands
up and it's like he's talking to someone
and then he says he'll get a lawyer and
schedule something then he leaves and
then his show is just dead air for 30
minutes and the rumor going around is
that he was arrested however many people
on the left are claiming it was a prank
or a publicity stunt
some are even claiming that behind the
scenes he's in a private chat room with
other proud boys and he's currently
talking however
an associate of
of his and from censored tv is saying
that he is in jail right now
it's hard to know what to make of this
um
because i i you know when i see this him
being interrupted during the live show a
lot of people are like what are the
chances that happens and it's like we've
been interrupted several times with the
police come here because we were swatted
and there are a lot of people claiming
that we were faking it and we weren't we
had like you actually could see the
police walk in the room the first time
it happened and i think the not the last
time because um to be honest when it's
happened following that we haven't said
anything we have armed guards you know
and other security that i'm not going to
mention and they will you know intercept
any
let's just say security issues
so we just don't say anything about it
and um you know obviously but uh there
was you know i think a month ago we had
the cops sweep the room it was a wide
shot so when i see the story i'm like i
don't know man maybe maybe got arrested
but maybe it's not related to anything
crazy like if he did maybe it's because
he like i don't know stole the newspaper
or something who knows or he like got
into a civil dispute another arguing i
have no idea but uh
story is certainly going wild so if it
is a stunt it is a brilliant one and
it's working i guess but i'm not going
to start off by assuming that someone
would ditch their own show to do
something like this
don't know for sure
on top of that though we have new
information coming out from the trump
raid
and uh i i look it's my opinion but i
think right now it is it is
definitively fbi corruption
the affidavit mostly redacted basically
said that donald trump cooperated by
turning over 15 boxes and within those
boxes was classified materials therefore
they have they said we now have reason
to believe he's probably got more so we
should get to search his his home then
they went in and took 11 documents or 11
packets or something and cash patel said
that those were russiagate documents
could it be that right before midterm
they were scared that trump would
release crossfire hurricane russia gate
evidence that made the government look
bad so they needed a way to justify
going to his house and taking the copies
or at least trying to find out what he
has i don't know i don't know for sure i
don't want to get too conspiratorial
what i do know is it sounds like from
this affidavit if trump did not
cooperate with the feds they would not
have had means or grounds to actually go
into his home so it's very very crazy
we're going to get to that and a whole
lot more governor hocal in new york said
republicans are not new yorkers or what
did she say something like that like
told him to go back to florida is that
what you said yeah wow
i guess we'll talk all about that but
ladies and gentlemen tonight's show is
sponsored by tim cast records
head over to timcastrecords.com
or you'll see in the in the description
below is a link to bandcamp
um we also are selling this new song
only ever wanted our first single from
tim cass records on apple music and a
lot of people were like i ain't gonna
buy off apple it's like okay band camp
you know they're all right here's the
thing
we have one week
we have we have very little time to
maximize the amount of of purchases of
the song in order to actually uh chart
and have an impact and we're the whole
point of this is we want to
invade the cultural space of the
establishment so here's what i'm going
to say to all y'all at midnight well
actually 1201 a.m this morning we
launched the song only ever wanted
official video you can see it right here
let me show you
there it is we right now have like 450
000 hits on this song in what are we
looking at like 20 hours i think it's
been yeah in less than one day and
that's just on youtube so on other
platforms there's also it's like i think
maybe like 80 to 100k on instagram which
doesn't really count towards anything
and uh so all in all
i would already say huge success for our
like initial launch of a song that we
wrote we've got many more coming we're
gonna be signing more bands just like
the daily wires doing movies you know
we're doing something similar we had
pete parada he was he was a drummer from
the offspring and a whole bunch of other
bands like face to face and they fired
him because he could not get the vaccine
so it is an honor and a privilege to
have worked with him on this song and
that's what we're going to do we are
going to take the hill that they have
abandoned if you want to support us and
you want to send a message you want to
help us continually take this space
the link in the description in
description below 69 cents to buy the
song at all costs and you don't need
that many to have an impact to get on
the charts so if you guys go down there
and just buy that song put in your
libraries it's also on amazon music and
stuff it would be a dream come true it'd
be tremendous and hopefully we we can
generate enough from this
to keep making more music and then if
there are other people who are scared
you know here's what i'm here i wanna
tell you what i'm talking about
people in the music industry who are
like i agree with all of this stuff oh i
voted for donald trump but if i tell
anybody i'll get fired i want there to
be within a few years a space a parallel
cultural economy where people can be
like bro if you fire me i'm going to go
work for this other company daily daily
wire
yeah daily wire they're already doing it
they hired a disney executive we need
more of this so um you know i'll say
outright
i wish
you know
anybody else could be doing this kind of
stuff too there's many people who are
doing it all i know is i'm going to do
everything i can and with your support
we'll do more so that being said links
in the description below joining us oh
oh oh and don't forget timcast.com of
course
being a member at 10ks.com is what's
making all this possible that's like the
main engine for us to make all these
shows and you can see here that we've
got
cast castle vlog which is comedy we're
going to be making we're turning into a
sitcom tails from the inverted world
true crime pop culture crisis pop
culture commentary chicken city family
friendly you know just chicken stuff we
are trying chicken stuff we're trying to
build the cultural space and expand it
and we are building more and more and
more and what's happening is once we get
a project established and and the gears
start turning we move on to the next one
we just keep planting more seeds whose
trees whose shade we know we will never
sit beneath that's the whole goal so
become a member at timcast.com support
our work joining us to talk about all of
this crazy stuff and probably a lot of
cultural stuff is g prime85 thank you
again for the invite
go go ahead
am i allowed to introduce myself no no
okay
well i will say then simply i am the
wandering cartoonist who serves no
master that's right i am reddit's
favorite martial arts expert
you guys know what i'm talking about yes
and i am in fact
it's called
and i'm the only one you guys ever
wanted oh oh my that's right we have we
have uh we got a couple of george's uh
it's george's awesome comics my favorite
is the joe biden electrocuting people
with force lightning it's just
absolutely amazing i was there yeah
we are also joined by hannah claire
bremelo hi i'm hannah claire brimlow i'm
a writer for timcast.com
hi everyone how's easy hannah claire
talk about other stuff if you guys want
hey george what's your website i'll
mention it again at the end i think well
i think the best way uh is just g
prime85 on twitter and instagram and i
have all my links on there oh yeah and
tim cast records will be releasing g
prime's first rap song oh yeah yeah look
at that beard i'm announcing this
without actually consulting
and if you guys want i'm trying to
convince him to play uh only ever wanted
on the show tonight and i don't know if
it's going to happen maybe we'll play
out the show maybe maybe maybe we'll do
maybe we'll play some songs we can ask
carter to come in oh not live i mean if
can we roll the video at the end of the
song and just let it roll us out i don't
know i don't have the file don't have
the capacity oh i could play it on
youtube the youtube video yeah yeah
we could buy the mp3 we'll taste the
freedom to buy our own for how much what
a great 69
it's elon musk you know he's a big fan
of that number and so no you're given
three options to sell songs for 129 99
and 69 cents
and so there the strategy is basically
if you have a die hard fan base they
sell it for 129 because they know it'll
sell no matter what and then if you're
looking for just maximum sales you sell
it for the lower amount so we're not
we're not looking for i'm not trying to
make a million dollars off this song i'm
trying to have an impact inspire young
people and set the space i'll tell you
guys this right now going through all
the billboard numbers it's actually
really funny when you look at the
billboard hot 100 the most popular songs
in the country it's all like you know r
rnb hip-hop you know
whop you know what i mean was it wap the
thing bench bench bureau
the reason that is is because people
listen to that that stuff but if every
fan
of like metal or alternative
actually bought the songs
then the high 100 would always be
alternative rock yeah a coordinated uh
marketplace when the when the demand can
coordinate you can kind of control
production in a sense i'll just i'll
just put it this way like i i i won't
say too much but it does not take that
many people to buy a song to get you in
the top charts the issue is no one does
so the reason so like i'll say is if we
saw john rich he hit number one on
itunes i think for like 12 days or
something like that yeah great progress
a country song ragging on woke people
yeah because his fans actually bought it
that's what that's what i'm talking
about so even if it's not like this song
is totally not political
we need y'all to just support your
favorite artists and then all of a
sudden we'll start displacing the top
charts and then if you do that those
record labels are going to be like hey
guys this makes more money this sells
better and shout out to shane and nancy
cashman the actors in the video if you
guys haven't seen only ever wanted the
music video you got to go to it and
watch it tonight at some point and um
they look great their eyes man there's
just so much emotion in the eyes i'm
really really happy with kent welling's
editing and shooting of the video too
it's fantastic there was a comment viva
fry posted the promo and then someone
responded to him saying cringe i'm
surprised the glass from the car crash
didn't form angel wings behind her in
the end
i responded with whoa that's a good idea
yes
magic oh yeah i am also here in the
corner it's friday evening i'm leaning
on my pillow because my arm is killing
me but i'm here to push buttons and
let's talk about the news here's the
first story the reason this story is
important because um gavin mcinnis may
have been arrested we don't know the
daily dot who um likely just hates gavin
writes was proud boys founder gavin
mcinnes actually arrested following his
live stream well i believe it's
betridge's law is that it you want
someone factual man this one she has
never heard of bachelor's law of
headlines if a headline asks a question
the answer is no that's correct yeah i
have heard that is it better i don't
know if i'll look up things what do we
got so much fast typing in this room
yeah come on guys better edge's law of
headlines boom i can't believe i
remembered that properly i'm always
mixing it up it was better so uh here's
what here's what happens there's this
video of gavin he's doing his show i
think we can play this named after ian
betterage hey really an ian a british
technology technology journalist so
here's here's gavin mcinnis we're
shooting a show can we do this another
time
and then he gets up and he he like
doesn't say anything for a little while
and then it's really quiet because he's
away from the mic
he says uh let's see when's going to say
it i think we got to jump in sit down
and have a conversation we'll schedule a
meeting
and we'll sit down with my lawyer yeah
he says well we'll schedule a meeting
we'll sit down with my lawyer now i'll
say this
a lot of people are like it's got to be
the feds because um i think it was will
carless this journalist called the local
police and they're like we did not
arrest him and there's been no
announcements by law enforcement or
anything about a possible arrest
who knows what's happening is he in the
u.s or canada he's in new york this is
the kind of thing where you
law enforcement i believe they would
make a big headline out of this i don't
think so gavin no that's a privacy
violation i'm pretty sure they wouldn't
just arbitrarily announce we have
arrested this man but with it with trump
they were like we have went into
mar-a-lago wasn't that a big deal he was
the one who announced they went to
mar-a-lago and and with roger stone they
tipped off cnn so it depends on what the
police government wants to happen i
don't want to think of this because
gavin's a master troll like the proud
boys is a master troll he did he set
that com that cup that group up as a
troll and
but i don't want to like talk to say
that if he actually got arrested because
that's you know i don't i don't i don't
i don't care who you are
i'm even even the boy who cried wolf in
a circumstance like this i'm not going
to start by assuming you fat you faked
some kind of arrest or something and you
got you got to understand too in this
clip
he didn't even say he was getting
arrested he just left the show in the
middle of the show for all we know
when he was pulling into his driveway he
scratched his neighbor he bumped his
neighbor's car and they called the cops
and he's doing a show and the cop shows
up and then they said like you hit that
car you got to come out and he's like
i'll get a life like it could have been
something as innocuous as that and then
they were like no you're coming out now
and then the show goes off the air
because he's outside and he's like
arguing with people and exchanging
information and they're yelling at him
who knows did they leave the show
running after that yeah they they're
running so josh denney who is associated
with gavin mcguinness and censored tv
says just got off the phone with our
people it's not a bit gavin was against
going to january 6. he was against
charlottesville and told proud boys they
were out of the club if they went but
he's rotting away in jail because he
dared to question authority oh wow you
know i kind of feel like it's hard to
believe what do you think
i
don't
think it's hard to believe that gavin is
against january 6th no no no no
publicized i think getting arrested i
know he's against january 6 because he's
i
i'm where to comment on this
there's a part of the video where he
says uh i didn't let you in here and i
don't know a ton about gavin studio but
that i think that's significant that
either means that they
um
felt like they had reason to entry a
reason to enter and i assume that means
they were serving an arrest warrant it's
hard not to see it that way
um i don't think
that
you know he's been silent ever since so
that's also significant i think his fan
or his i think his company or he would
address it in some way if everything
were fine if that makes sense i think
the fact that we are not hearing
anything
the longer it goes on becomes
increasingly more suspicious
will carless said trying to confirm
what's up with gavin mcguinness abruptly
leaving his show last night in the
middle of his live stream a colleague of
his tweeted mckinnis was hauled off by
the feds but no charges filed on pacer
or press releases from doj fbi no so
reserving judgment fair point fair point
i don't know
i don't know because you know ian you
mentioned that he's a master troll he
certainly is but i will say
scott adams
remember what he tweeted july 1st 2020
yeah i do i remember it he said
republicans will be hunted everyone made
fun of him and then it was two months
later that aaron danielson took two to
the chest from uh from a black lives
matter activist with a blm tattoo on his
neck
someone was just insinuating that mega
republicans were dangerous
mega republicans but it was like they
specified this these mega who was that i
was on twitter i think it was today even
was it a problem republicans it was
biden wasn't it yeah
i don't know like
have you guys seen the trailer older man
who keeps just rambling i don't know
have you guys seen the trailer for my
son hunter oh gosh no
not trailer i just thought exists i saw
the trailer it looks really good gina
chrono's in it oh cool but my only my
only my only issue with it is that it
makes joe biden look very strong
incorrect inaccurate yeah because like
he's like there's like a scene where he
confronts hunter and he's like what did
you do and then i'm like joe
he'd be going like come on man
crack pipe
porn pop
what are you doing to me man unless
unless the angle they're going with is
that it's an all it's all an act so that
his enemies think he's a fumbling
bumbling you know look people people are
like i'll put it this way conservatives
are acting like joe biden's not really
the one making all these moves so he's
sort of getting the blame deflected off
of himself by by being this way so
imagine he's actually totally lucid and
strong and he's like listen here listen
to your champ i just made a bunch of
moves guy look fat i'm the one taking
the economy but i'm not going to take
the blame for it watch how i pull this
one off
what
economy
that's the thing
ronald reagan apparently when he was
leaving office he had also apparently
had alzheimer's that's the story but
some people think that he had been
embroiled in some corruption and it was
coming out and then he started saying
like i can't remember i don't remember i
don't remember and his memory started to
fail him all of a sudden and then he was
off the hook yeah they're going to be
like they're going to so the republicans
are going to win they're going to file
investigations
in november and then they're going to
subpoena joe biden and he's going to be
like
uh i did what and you're going to be
like mr president you had a conversation
with the president of ukraine about a
billion dollar loan guarantee
a billion dollar bone guarantee wha
what are they
there were all these stories about like
this is starting to seem like elder
abuse like i think everyone was saying
like he's just he seems so out of it
that it it's almost cruel to force him
to do this i don't necessarily agree but
like in some ways i wondered if that
story was to set him up for like
sympathy from the american public should
anyone ever try to prosecute him in the
future because it's like well he wasn't
he wasn't well then and he's not he's
even worse now like
we we always just give him the excuse
that he's like old and decrepit even
though he was
this way when we elected him maybe maybe
he is
being
controlled by somebody else and he's
just a puppet maybe he's secretly strong
either way you've got a conspiracy
theory on your hands but this is what i
want to get to if this gavin mcginnis
thing turns out to not be a hoax and he
was actually detained for some reason
then uh
the fact that information's been
withheld and that he he would be in jail
is actually really really terrifying
which is why it's like it'd be really
awful if it was a stunt or some kind of
prank or something he might come back
and be like i didn't prank anybody you
know i got into an argument with a
neighbor and then we cancelled the show
and then everyone started claiming i was
arrested like what happened you know
fraud could be like that
but considering that the the president
just got his home his house rated and
and the reasoning behind it seems to be
completely
like fraudulent and corrupt in my
opinion
these are these are scary days you know
like i mentioned scott adams said
republicans will be hunted
he did say you'll be dead by this time
next year yeah or something like that
but a couple months later dude was shot
and killed with just being a trump
supporter so it's like
it was right for somebody and if you
mean it in like the unpersonal way like
if you ban people from platforms that
are mainstream and you cut them off from
society you're not literally dead but
you are uh
your influence is over if that makes
sense that's that's what i think more
people the attempt is with most people
who have like mega ideology they don't
want them to have any sort of influence
over politics so if they can shuffle
them as far into the dark parts of the
internet as they can and be like oh
they're extremists you know that's the
that's the ideal scenario so let's let's
um
let me let me start by saying
i'm looking i'm really excited for
november you know people pointed out
that new york 19 was supposed to go
republican but stayed democrat so that's
a bad sign but then someone else pointed
out that uh the democrats won that
district by 12 points they just won it
again by two which suggests a major
swing in favor of republicans so i just
want to make sure everybody's got that
little optimism in their minds and i
will also add two on the culture front
we released a song it's got 480 000 hits
probably like more than that with across
the platforms so like things are going
really well like i'm actually i'm
feeling pretty good daily wire is hiring
disney cmo like the market you know like
i think we're doing really well and
every day
the the the cult seems to just falter
and and fail and stumble that being said
in their desperation
you will see the death throws and the
death rattles
so
going after donald trump's home raiding
it
gavin mcginnis maybe being rated or
arrested i don't know desperation yeah
but desperation
project veritas getting raided and now
we got the story in the new york times
about these people
selling the diary actually biden's diary
to james and it sounds like they're
going to try and go after veritas
we may be winning but of course no one
in the culture war is going to just give
up right yeah so if freedom liberty
moderation libertarianism conservative
values american values all of these
things which don't completely agree with
each other but have this coalition start
winning are we about to see a dramatic
escalation in corrupt law enforcement
and political you know
authoritarianism well surely they're
going to be held accountable after the
next couple months and they can't allow
that
i mean when a cornered animal lashes out
you know in its last desperate move
that's when
the republicans have the advantage of
typically they are the party of inaction
i would say and in this case inaction is
probably the best thing to do really
they're being provoked
into do something make a mistake but
actually just by sitting and waiting
until november that's probably the best
move for most the center and the right
go tell all your family members to vote
and go vote yourself
replace all the jerks
and then hopefully the rep the
representatives who are elected are
going to be able to clean up instead of
trying to
uh seize the ring of power for
themselves and then the corruption
spreads but it comes from the right now
i gotta give
i gotta give an amazing white pill
moment for everybody i was laughing with
such a joy earlier today
so i tweeted out that youtube changed
their rules right
i did this big long thing because
youtube removed the rule saying you you
can't claim that that masks cause lung
cancer and that masks uh uh
you know a whole bunch of claims the
most absurd of which was that
youtube now allows people to claim that
masks cause lung cancer which is weird
it's insane yeah and so i did this big
thing of all the rules right but one of
them was about the efficacy of the
vaccines and marjorie taylor green
tweeted me and said so in other words
allowing some truth
some truth something like that she was
not endorsing any of the stuff a bunch
of outlets wrote articles claiming
marjorie taylor green endorses idea that
masks caused lung cancer and then i just
busted out laughing
she certainly did not
she was making a comment about reduction
in censorship some of which these things
are actually asserted by the cdc she did
not say masks do this it's like saying
there's some good people in the united
states and people being like you think
murderers are good people exactly
what's that joke i like pancakes yeah
are you saying you hate waffles yes yes
so i i just laughed i'm like this is all
they have
this is what the media has now they're
so desperate so they're front they're
they're they're scraping at the bottom
of the barrel so hard they've started
pulling up wood chips yeah and the
timing is right after she's been swatted
what twice so they're like no sympathy
points for her she thinks masks give
make you have lung cancer stay away from
arjun taylor green like it's so
desperate what they're doing there's
another fake meme where they're like
marjorie taylor green was talking about
solar energy and claimed that you would
lose electricity at night and she said i
don't know about you but i like having
the lights on at night
and then all these leftists are mocking
her and i'm like
are you joking she's right solar panels
don't work at night and so the issue is
with with solar power as a grid feature
is that you need massive batteries
better better technology that we don't
actually have and so that's why solar
works great supplemented by natural gas
was that her point because that's
actually correct but they snip out one
weird sounding thing
anyway the reason i bring that up as a
white pill thing
when we're talking about winning in
november g prime you know he just
mentioned george she said get your
family go vote
know marjory tends everybody you know
everybody you know when marjorie taylor
green
is is winning
and she's like raising more money than
anybody else and then we see a whole
bunch of maga republicans that they hate
so much winning carrie lake sweeping
every district in arizona arizona's been
slowly turning blue because of
california people fleeing california
kerry lake still swept every district
it's that border yo the border i'm
saying
after everything i've seen this year
trump's endorsement record is like 99
success crazy
i'm ready to order a bunch of nachos sit
back grab some beers and be like this is
good news everybody some organic just
make sure make sure you don't you don't
just rest on on these victories you have
to make sure now
you know when the enemy the center has
has crumpled you don't just go okay it
crumpled we can chill no no no now you
take the hilltop
so come november everybody you got to
get everybody you know
and then finally
if we can get enough of these actual
american value politicians in maybe get
some accountability and some investments
good point if you truly if you really
win which it feels like sometimes i feel
like i am winning in life like this is a
this is a victory so then it's your turn
to build you now have the land the land
is yours now you must create something
sustainable so that you can you and your
friends can stay you and your people
your your brethren it's really red
team's game to lose
in sports terms it's sort of like um
conservatives in general strategically
are hold your ground and play defense
it's hard to go on offense with your
shield up you're stepping forward
stepping forward holding your ground but
now it's time to you have the ball go
towards the end zone
i guess my problem is that i worry that
i mean we grew up we're all about the
age where we remember when the
republicans pushed a little too hard in
the early 2000s and stuff we've seen
them
go on offense and then make so many
mistakes that they make themselves look
foolish
and then they get replaced by the left
because the left says we want change
from these bad policies these i always
talk about the patriarch and all that
stuff i hate that stuff and the and
pushing wars and let's go invade
everybody it's like no how about we just
focus on america for a little while and
that's what
this new form of uh red team is doing i
want to see what happens when they have
control of the ball
um i i don't we've never seen what
happens before have we i don't think we
have well how do you see america fitting
in with a new world order
uh it depends who's in control of
america right i mean if
if in the next two and a half years by
and still in control of the executive
branch let's say or his handlers are
still in control
uh legislative might lean
red uh supreme court's leaning red now
so i'm guessing it's going to be lame
duckish for the next couple years maybe
policy wise as far as the new world
order is concerned uh they might just be
planning to do things without america's
involvement
would be my guess because america is
kind of crippled as if we have a blue
executive branch who won't
pass any of the legislation that they
write
on
red team let's say we want to pass these
bills and job buttons like no i'm just
not going to pass it not going to pass
it so then it goes to the supreme court
and then we have more fighting on that
front but as far as what they're trying
to push like what
i mean what new thing is going to happen
next two years that the liberal world
order or whatever the world economic
forum what are they going to try to push
in the next couple of years aside from
cryptocurrency as the new digital
currency like dispensing of the dollar
erosion of human rights in general
we'll just i guess we will be watching
helplessly as the rest of the world
loses their rights and then hoping that
we're one of the last countries that can
at least openly criticize this stuff
yeah whenever there's a revolution ah
honestly i don't think there's ever been
a revolution i was reading about this
where the the bottom tier of society
rose up and took the top it's always
that
a top and a bottom aspect of society are
replaced by a smaller top and bottom
segment of society so
and it's so it's like you can't well
that that maybe is a little different
than the point of that you can't really
revolt a system doesn't revolt alone
it's with because of outside forces like
the french won the american revolution
yeah that'll be very strange if let's
say there's um
uprisings throughout the america i was
talking about this yesterday i think
they might try to import uh like private
military from other countries to try to
be peacekeepers or something that would
be absolutely horrifying or maybe we
were talking about this offline with
those stupid uh boston
dynamics robots
patrolling down the street
trying to hold the hold the piece in
like new york state or something if
there's like weirdos in the woods trying
to hold their ground i guess are there
peaceful revolutions in history like are
there you guys know of any i can't name
one off top of my head i guess he's full
um but there there are a couple examples
i can't i can't remember what's up my
head though
throughout the bankers like in 2008 they
were like we're done with central banks
we're taking control of our money didn't
didn't canada just be like hey we're
gonna go our own way oh and they were
like okay canada
something like that i don't know there
there have been but they're extremely
rare
yeah
i'll remember that
video
uh let's uh jump to the story here from
timcast.com oh yeah
governor kathy hokel to states
republicans you are not new yorkers okay
if you are a republican living in new
york um
[Music]
who is that uh who's that uh republican
that we know who lives in new york frank
frank jonathan frank i'm just like i'm
just saying that because there's a bunch
okay it looks like naming eminence
there's other ones i know there's more
no
you mean quite frankly
frank himself
yeah dude i love what's up right so uh
kathy hokel's gotta go said republican
congressman and gubernatorial candidate
lee zeldin
just jump on a bus and head down to
florida where you belong okay
okay bye
get out of town because you don't
represent our values wtf yeah
you are not new yorkers
wow there are like 5.4 million
registered republicans and like there
are probably independents who also lean
republican you guys should probably at
least get a plane ticket to florida
start seeing yourself out unelected
leader telling people ejecting people
like this is not good this is not an
american value man this is not something
we've ever really in my experience done
to our population before but it is
something that the nazis did to the jews
you don't repopulation was like an old
punishment say the words
liberal international economy
the two words dmt make everyone take a
shot come on uh
civil war yeah
you liked it
when the governor tells 5.4 million
people to get out of the state at a
rally for other political leaders dude
crap when the previous governor murdered
15 000 elderly people
i'm saying that
yeah there's a huge
one of the big criticism of this is like
do you not understand like we've already
lost a ton of people because of the
pandemic like that's our tax base you do
dude did you see
listen my friends the other day we were
talking about nate silver he said
liberal elites
pressured pfizer to with to hold back
the vaccine until after the election i
guess it was like to hurt trump or
something
that's what that's what nate silver was
saying
okay assuming that's true
these democrat politicians expected you
to die
in order to stop donald trump in fact
cuomo had the option to use that medical
ship which one was it it wasn't the
mercy
i thought it was but someone kept
telling me we were wrong oh i don't know
there was that big boat yeah there was
about and the javits center and cuomo
was like you know i could
i'm gonna put the sick people in the
elderly home yeah and then 15 000 people
died yep that took a lot of voters out
of the equation i'll tell you that it's
the u.s comfort it was the comfort of
york yeah yeah there and it 15 000
voters who are older who tend to be
conservative right erased from the
voting bloc older people tend to vote
republican
and then we saw it in what pennsylvania
in michigan in new jersey and in
california yeah the the this is this is
dark stuff this is part of why uh
top-down governance is failing or at
least struggling is because it's like
utilitarian they don't kathy doesn't
know all the republicans that she's
claiming are not new yorkers that are
like if she knew them personally she
probably wouldn't be saying that well
she always says like i'm from buffalo
from upstate i know about the rest of
new yorkers like she tries to present
herself as more than just like a
politician who's catering to
new york city which dominates the
state's politics in a lot of ways but
like she is not i'd bring up the uh
economic criticism because the two major
issues for new york voters right now are
crime and the economy and right now she
says i don't care about the economy i
don't want any republicans here and
before she's running against lee zeldin
who has to remember
someone tried to stab him on stage and
he correctly predicted that person would
be released before morning and they and
the attacker was i mean live in new york
it doesn't make any sense hold on i
think she's right
she's like she said she said you gotta
go what did you say jump on a bus and
head down to florida republicans in new
york i'm going to tell you just jump on
a bus and head down to florida yeah
florida florida needs you and florida's
great i say stay and fight though maybe
she's going to start busting them down
the way that like abbott's busting
illegal immigrants to dc like she's
gonna get her own system going but you
saw that story that they're not even
making it right they're like the buses
yeah yeah it's just you think it's
better to stay in new york and change it
from the inside i've had the opinion for
a long time it's what their what blue
team seems to be doing is forcing people
to retreat and i've always had the
opinion of the more you retreat
eventually you're going to find your
back to a cliff and then they're going
to force you to jump or do a desperate
move to make a mistake
i know a bunch of new yorkers because i
live really close to it and the idea of
um how do i put this
they will never forget like say you had
an older family member in the hospital
or something like that you weren't
allowed to visit them
or uh you had one you could only have
one person visiting at a time
uh that is how you can flip most
demographics read for sure nobody's
going to ever forget that at least from
our generation so not being able to
visit an elderly family member god
forbid you had someone that died
those people will never vote blue again
probably um so when she says leave she's
trying to force them to retreat because
she knows she's already lost them so
don't leave in fact stay in place i know
i've known a bunch of new yorkers who
they're always talking about is it time
to go is it time to go i say no you
should reclaim your land you should not
say
i'm gonna go somewhere else where i can
be happy
blue team's strategy seems to be to try
to make you run away
uh it's like a paper tiger kind of thing
you've already lost the fight you may as
well not fight now because you've lost
but actually there's way more of you
than you think especially in new york
state here's the thing too if every
single
uh
if every single republican in aoc's
district actually voted republican right
they would win they think that by
it's like oh i'm going to lose anyway so
i may as well not vote that's probably
what it is
i don't think even a lot of people know
that there's an election coming up in
the next few months but it's uh who who
just uh uh won the republican nomination
tina something in new york in aoc's
district uh i can look yeah look at i'm
cause i'm i'm drawing a blank on the
name but um
yeah she has a real thick accent it's
it's like i think it's it's what two to
one or three no it's like it's like
three to one democrat to republican and
in her district it's like d plus 25 or
something
but if you look at the amount of people
that actually turn out it's really
really low tina forte is that her name
yeah you know four days is that it four
to four because they don't realize how
important it is but but i will be
realistic you would need every single
republican
and conservative leaning person
every single one grandma and then you
need to also hope the democrats don't
turn out
the democrats typically don't turn out
like aoc i think got like a hundred and
something thousand out in a district of
750 000.
if every conservative voted it would it
would be the weirdest thing ever they'd
be like how did new york 14 flip
republican it's like because the
republicans got fed up and they actually
went out and voted i think a lot of
those votes though are people who are
they've been dead for a while maybe now
this is just my opinion i'm not saying
the f word but a lot of those people
like you know they recycle social
security numbers and stuff that's an
easy out yeah
there's a lot of corruption in new york
sure sure sure i'm all in favor of
cleaning up voter rolls but i think it's
such
what i don't like is that in 2016
they screamed for years that russia
hacked the machines and all that stuff
and then to see the right start using
that narrative and i'm like bro even if
it's the case you need to talk there's
two big things you need to do one rally
everyone you know to go and vote and two
make sure you're paying attention to the
process sure like in wisconsin they're
saying those drop boxes are illegal but
when you come out and you say stuff like
that it's like a defeatist mentality no
no
in fact we should overwhelm i say we as
if i'm on red team necessarily i i like
them but we should go in overwhelming
numbers so even if someone were to cheat
which never happens
they can't win because the numbers are
going to be so overwhelmingly on your
side here's here's what i think is
important when it comes to politics
if you're not cheating you're not trying
there's no such th the whole the whole
game is fight for power by any means
necessary now there are certain
parameters where things are flexible
albeit amoral or wrong and then there
are certain parameters where you're
outright committing criminal activity
proving criminal activity is very very
difficult and rarely happens it happens
sometimes desantis just found a bunch of
people who weren't eligible to vote were
voting and things like that
so when people come out and they assert
that the reason we lost is specifically
because of criminal activity it's like
or are you just not paying attention to
the fact that the rules were adjusted in
such a way that it harmed you and your
ideology pennsylvania is the best
example they changed the rules a year in
advance they cut a deal with republicans
to expand universal mail-in voting which
deeply hurts republican areas and deeply
benefits blue areas pay attention to
those things
but i don't i just
we've got to maintain that um that we're
going to win mentality and not not be
too focused on sure i definitely don't
want to reinforce the idea that we may
as well not bother because they're going
to cheat i still think
red team can overwhelmingly win just by
convincing family members say you got
people at church that
don't vote because they just don't want
to or maybe they're lazy or something
just convince them how important it is
and they already know how important
here's the other issue i have like if
you think they are cheating why aren't
the other side why is the other side
cheating like why is it only ever though
this like you're the opponents of your
person i just want lots of
accountability those are awesome by the
way the green tea these yeah i got a
story to tell you about this later
i know i love these they're sugar free
and they're super good for me yeah you
know anyway anyway i'll tell you later
you know it's it's always like the other
side is cheating and it's just like
if you think the establishment
republicans aren't playing games you
know what i mean it's it's one big
political machine right that's what i'm
that's what i'm saying i would love
accountability on both sides yeah
especially with the machines themselves
right now we've got paper man i would
love it or or at least digital machines
with transparent algorithms so that we
can watch the counts happen in real time
and then you can verify your vote and as
opposed to what they did and what they
have been doing is that they were
telling them in back rooms with
proprietary software code yeah so we
can't verify that the votes are even
being tallied properly the first
verification the ian you are completely
correct the first thing that we need to
do is open source publicly accessible
source code on all of our voting
equipment why not or a switch to paper
ballots or something or both or both
yeah yep yep yep i think a three step
like a three barriers would be so you
have your paper you have your digital
machine thing and then you have a
blockchain tally as well we're
relatively young in that we understand
what it means to say open source but how
do we convince people in like the
legislative branches what this means and
why it's important i don't think public
accountability
public accountability systems i i've got
private companies controlling our
elections is a conflict of interest yeah
i um i think they would all get that i
mean these are all words that they were
familiar with
universal
voting
access
sure voter transparency i want to point
you guys at a video of a testimony a guy
gave in front of congress if you want to
say what can we do with congress about
building an algorithm in a voting
machine that changes the vote 5149 oh
yeah and that no one unless you have the
source code you wouldn't know that it's
doing it or unless you could uh run it
up against
the uh
the actual paper ballots you wouldn't
know that anyone's doing it that's his
testimony it's like when you ask them uh
how do we know it's secure it's hashtag
trust me bro yeah it really is yeah yeah
and he it's so easy to verify his
testimony said that in the year 2000 he
built this foreign ohio
uh was it a senator i should be able to
have this this thing bookmarked this
testimony bookmarked it's on youtube
i'll pull it up within a minute i think
one of the most striking things about
this is that she's so i mean i think we
have this idea that like when people get
to the you know she won her democratic
primary uh that they'll start trying to
court the independent vote and move to a
more moderate position but with this
cultural hokul is just like blatantly
going farther left she is trying to
completely activate only democratic
voters and
that is fascinating to me she thinks she
can win on complete liberal rage alone
so we need we need to activate nuclear
dark ultra maga yeah this is the
testimony that people need to see it's
eugene uh the video on youtube if you
want to watch it's called american
election hacker testifies and it's from
i don't know 10 years ago or something
but uh the guy's name is clinton eugene
curtis he testified under oath in front
of the u.s house judiciary members in
ohio that tom feeney in the year 2000
had him build a prototype software
package that would secretly rig an
election to sway the result 5149 to a
specified side under oath testimony that
he built that for uh tom feeney
i was at um i've gone to a whole bunch
of the def con conferences and they have
like they have the voting hacker village
or something like that where they have a
bunch of different voting machines and
they're all just having a good time
breaking into them
so open source can help solve a lot of
that because it allows the public to
scrutinize how the system is being
operated that's that's really important
right now the voting machines can't
handshake with some machine remotely a
million miles away yeah they can't have
it so that you can't it doesn't connect
to anything outside like
um that would be nice too but like so
with a proprietary software voting
machine you could have like 100 people
vote and the machine's like
if the vote is this then subtract 10
from side a
and so it there will be a thing but if
you don't have the code to see the math
of what it's telling you what to
subtract and what to add you wouldn't
know that it's moving the votes but if
you can see the code then you'll see oh
there's something telling the machine to
subtract 10 if that's not right it
shouldn't be doing that it should just
be doing an honest tally
that's where we say accountability like
honestly this kind of code i'm not like
an expert by any means and you know way
more than me but i'm sure like most
amateur coders know how to tally things
this is not difficult it's it's trying
to uh account for all the weird things
like what if
i scan a vote and it doesn't go through
and then we have to scan it again does
it delete the original scan should
should the ballots have like should they
should they be serialized so that there
can't be repeats you know what i mean
yeah
i mean these are real like easy
questions bitcoin could solve this
crypto crypto could solve this uh if if
uh we've talked about crypto voting but
if we just do like a hybridized system
where when you vote
your your you know ballot has a has a
cryptographic association with your name
and your registration then you can't you
don't got to worry about them going
through the machine twice or anything
like that it's like you know rejected
already in the system
let me let me talk to you about the way
in which i think we are seeing
uh dirty underhanded tactics to try and
win
in these elections
from timcast.com
sandy hook families ask judge to remove
alex jones from control of his company
now i don't mean to say this story
literally specifically is democratic
operatives trying to cheat what i'm
saying is the things we have seen levied
at alex jones in general
are destroying his ability to run his
company
and
along with many other people the
censorship ramped up tremendously in
2018
and is still persistent with now the
revelation that the fbi made a request
to facebook and then facebook was like
oh we better censor this hunter button
laptop stuff
the moves made against donald trump the
moves made to censor stories the the the
destruction of alex jones in in fours
and all that stuff and for all of the
things you can criticize them for i get
it i get it the fact is they're going
after speech
this would not be necessary if they were
winning
they wouldn't need to go after alex
jones unless alex jones is actually a
threat to the establishment just saying
his name is giving him publicity that's
right
what's happening now is in the lawsuit
the families are alleging that he's
funneling money to uh free speech
systems his company is funneling money
to a family member i say according to
the motion free speech systems claims to
owe a massive secured debt to an insider
that was first reported when the cases
against jones began but no records show
that debt existed prior to the lawsuit
attorneys for the families are now
requesting a bankruptcy trustee assume
control of his company they have also
requested the court appoint a tort
claimant's comm committee to investigate
free speech systems business dealings
and for the court to remove fss as the
debtor in possession
this is kind of crazy
because people talked about this
when uh jones lost his lawsuit or i
shouldn't say when he lost it he was in
default but when he was sentenced to pay
you know 45 45 million or whatever 50
million
imagine
you uh kind of deal with someone legit
then they get sued
or let's say they're they're getting
sued and you don't know and you do a
deal with them now the court's coming
after you and they're going to take from
you because of something he did how is
that legal that to me is crazy i would
think that that would not be that's what
they're doing they're basically saying
that the other people who who owes money
to is illegitimate and should be
basically suspended
that's kind of crazy isn't it
desperation
this is what i think well look the
families are asking it and i think that
has a lot to do with they want the money
that they sued him over and if he's
broke ain't no money to get so this is
the course they take but my point is you
are seeing a lot of stuff launched at
alex jones you are seeing a lot of stuff
launched at a ton of people and it's
going to get crazier you think the
midterms are crazy it's like we're a
couple months out and it's getting nuts
they raided a former president's home
unprecedented imagine 2023 2024. it's
almost like they're throwing
spaghetti at a wall because they're
hoping some of it will stick that's
exactly what it feels like to me and it
does look like desperation like they're
getting crazy this is this is how you
know when your spaghetti is done you
guys know this right you throw it at the
wall you pull out a thing you throw it
at the wall if it sticks good i'm just
start doing that
you know what's good about saying alex
jones type of person not to speak for
him or anything but a lot of people on
the right are
people of faith let's say you get a
marjorie taylor green or something like
that
they are trained because of their faith
too
we are
it's like we're conditioned to suffer
and take it
and that's when the qualities of the
right shine the most is when you're
oppressing them and it's like wait why
aren't you staying down why do you keep
getting up and it's like no i actually
kind of love this
i think that oh no it's just they
worship a guy whose whole shtick is he
was beaten to death and then he came
back to life so it's like the more you
oppress say a christian or something
like that judeo-christian perhaps
the more they're like oh wait i'm
actually more in alignment with the
person who i'm supposed to be emulating
i find it's a psyop i think that the
catholic church on purpose made people
believe that they're supposed to suffer
and that they're bad so that they would
become servants to the church okay so
this is actually something that victor
frankl observed in his time and fidor
dostoevsky also observed it in his time
in concentration camp in soviet russia
he observed that people who followed
religions were impossible to stop you
could not keep them down they firmly
believed they were following what was
true and i think that's and i can you i
can obviously prove that that's 100
divorced from the church it had nothing
to do with the church this was something
that they held inside themselves they're
taught scripturally exactly this is what
like the hardcore disciples and say the
book of acts or something yeah you're
the most in alignment you're the closest
to being like the disciples who like
they're like no please torturing me more
so that my resurrection is better yeah
saint paul has said something like that
where it's like i want to have an even
more uh even uh
i don't know i want to get more buff
points or something when when i level up
and when i was yeah no because at the
very core of what they believe is that i
mean they don't talk about this very
often and maybe i'm going on a tangent
but
at the core of christianity is you
expect to be resurrected so even if
you're thrown to the lions literally in
early biblical times
tortured to death whatever that actually
brings you closer to
um
it's kind of like you you if you're not
being tortured maybe you're doing
something wrong right in fact in
revelation one of the things they were
talking about was how god despised the
lukewarm church yeah he's like you were
in either hot nor cold and for that
reason i spit you out of my mouth you're
just kind of there yeah you're just
there but i was talking about this the
other day and well i'm not going to
apologize but uh
talking about lukewarm christians and
that sort of thing and um even with the
vaccine mandates and you weren't allowed
to go to church or any of that stuff
i would still hear stories about people
going to church and meeting anyway even
though the state told them they weren't
allowed to yeah it's like that's where
you find where the lukewarm christians
were is the ones who kind of just like
oh i'll do whatever the state tells me
to it's like no actually in the early
church again we were meeting underground
when you could be found and killed you
know you remember i don't know
you know the origin of the jesus fish i
was gonna say that's what i was gonna
say yeah one person would would draw an
uh a crescent and then the other person
would finish it creating the shape of a
fish secret message so that you knew we
are fishers of men yeah exactly but
that's i mean honestly that's when you
you feel the heat of your faith really
is when you can die for it but you still
believe it anyway so i have family
members who are so
not to say too much out of respect but
like i know one that uh
was facing their death let's say or is
facing their death and that is when they
are the most themselves and everyone's
like how are you holding it together and
it's like no i'm gonna go see jesus soon
yeah yeah they
so again i'm complimenting christians in
the sense of like the more you push them
the more you force them to like hey
we're gonna be mean to you and we're
gonna dox you or we're gonna swat you
bring it they love it and actually i
don't know if the left understands this
because maybe they don't believe
anything i think they don't really
believe in christianity because they
dismiss it sort of out right
but like throughout the christian bible
they're the reminders of like uh set
your mind all the things above i think
there's a verse in colossians about that
where it's a constant reminder that like
what's happening on earth is not your
ultimate end goal and i think if you
aren't a person of faith that's very
difficult to embrace because like the
idea of eternity and the consequences of
your actions here you know for some
people this is all you have and so you
have to do whatever like whatever your
ultimate ideology is you have to pursue
it intensely whereas christians aren't
driven that's not their home i want to
address you know you you were mentioning
about getting backed into a corner and
then you know what you're talking about
did you say a rat or what you say just
like no just if i'm forced to retreat
eventually there's going to be a cliff
behind me you know what i was thinking
you guys see that video of the lady
being attacked by the rabid fox yeah
what the heck was that that made me feel
like the summer of love like the analogy
it's like you're sitting there minding
your own business you're watering your
lawn and a rabid fox just runs up and
attacks you for no reason and you try
and kick it off but it keeps biting you
then it bites onto her hand and she's
like swinging it around and then throws
it and then she's got a gash and she got
puncture wounds then she's got to get
the rabies shot and it's like man she
didn't even do anything to anybody right
that's how it felt with like the blm
riots so a lot of people talk about how
yet you know someone super chatted the
establishment is losing but a cornered
rat bites the hardest and i'm like you
got two choices you can go and water
your flowers and mind your own business
and the rabbit fox attacks you or you
can be proactive and chase it off with
the hose because they're hydrophobic and
then it might get into a corner and
freak out but what do you choose do you
choose to say i'm not going to allow you
to come under my house or you say i'm
just going to go over here and ignore
you and then you're eventually going to
bite me yeah i think being proactive and
saying no just saying no standing up
even if it means you know you're backing
backing the establishment that's that's
the problem i have i do believe that the
faith in god or in a perception in
something greater than the physical
experience that we're having is
important and it gives me faith in
saying what i believe regardless of
consequences often but the feeling of
being okay to be a servant is disturbing
to me because i think that's church
propaganda that they want people to be
subservient so that they don't rise up
and overthrow corrupt corrupt
governments and systems and
i don't like seeing people backed into a
corner i don't like seeing people act
out of fear i don't think they should
have to and if you're proactive you
don't have to because you put yourself
in a position of stability here's
here's what everyone's got to do
when someone's being mean to you on
twitter respond by just being nice even
if you don't want to
swallow your pride all right swallow
your pride
all right and then when someone says
something nasty to you just say
something nice back and leave it at that
choke on the rind
i don't know what that means but feel it
keep it empty
yeah
you're wondering some sweet lyrics my
favorite uh i mean quite literally like
a lot of it a lot of people will be like
i'm not this person slighted me i'm not
going to and i'm saying yes while you're
pride it means like don't
stand up and be like i refuse to accept
no no you have to accept that in
strategy and and being being a tactician
requires winning
winning is not someone insults you so he
insult him back all all you're doing is
flinging mud if you really want to win
someone insults you you be nice to them
and completely stop the fight the fight
you win is the fight you don't engage in
so that's what that's what i'm saying
well an interesting thing also to
consider uh to add to what you were
saying ian is uh at the bottom level or
the top level of christianity like i
don't think a lot of them practicing
understand how crazy this is like they
actually think that they will be
resurrected like actually and not in an
abstract way they mean like bodily like
in x thousand years yeah but i'm not
sure
a lot of people probably don't believe
it or it's too crazy i think that when i
talk to
the learned
religious folk they don't say stuff like
that it's too weird but it's that
because there's the thing of if you're a
servant and you let yourself be
controlled now
later you'll be a king and you're like
that's just a manipulation manipulation
tactic to get people to serve i believe
one could say that i mean biblically
speaking you could one could try to
argue that that those verses were added
later on down the road like when you
look at the different um
manuscript translations and they've
found a lot of old manuscripts that are
super super close to when the disciples
had written most of the new testament
the apostle and um
it's pretty much
they have not changed very much yeah
consciousness dude is going to rise your
spirit is alive and active or maybe not
alive in the sense of our bodies but
it's it's a it's a
momentous organism you could say it's
not of course it's not an organism it's
not carbon-based but
whether you're a slave in life or you're
a hero in life your soul is still going
to live on it's still going to be
thereafter well in that sense too like
you could just say the christian is
embodying what jesus did by
jesus still lives on through them by
them continuing what he said and
basically promised so when and to go
back to why an american would stand
their ground and why we love standing
our ground culturally
we are certain that by doing that the
next generations who inherit america
from us
are going to benefit by copying that
behavior i'm going to stand my ground
and not retreat and that will probably
end up preserving the country as opposed
to if i keep backing away and seeding
ground to enemies who keep trying to
push me
they will they don't even have to fight
me and they'll win the ground but if i
stand my ground and force them to fight
and engage me
it's going to get ugly and maybe it's
going to cost them more than they want
to pay
and
i'm sorry go ahead no i'm just and
forcing people to take you know they say
turn the other cheek it's like no i am
in fact willing to let you hit me and
i'm daring you now to hurt me even more
because eventually that will make me win
by default you are the aggressor you
lose like look what happened to rome it
became christian because they kept it
was originally a secret religion and you
were killed for believing it but
eventually it became the religion of
rome because among other reasons they
were persecuting them so hard everybody
became a christian
so i think about this with the raid on
donald trump and it looks like they're
trying to indict him on something i said
it before a lot of world leaders
historical leaders good and bad
the persecution led them to rise to
power yeah good leaders that we like in
history and bad leaders we don't like in
history you know making someone into a
political martyr doesn't tend to work
out for their enemies it makes yeah it
makes you look like
hey why are you being mean to him i'm
going to go support him i want to
support the under i think that's why
this like attempted complete decimation
of alex jones at infowars as a whole is
miscalculated i think there is like
if you are part of sandy hook families
it's much more emotional i think there
are politics behind it but of course
there's it's more complicated
but i think
ultimately they need alex jones to not
become a martyr so they need a complete
wipeout they can't leave any remnants of
what he's left behind because of one in
a lot of ways he was a huge he was a
gateway for a lot of people to become
supportive of donald trump and they
can't have that again i think it was
james lindsay who mentioned on the show
that he was like on a plane with a woman
and then she said that she didn't like
trump but this raid against him was was
wrong and it was a step too far right
they shocked the system hard and i think
let's actually just jump to the story
okay so we have this uh from the wall
street journal
judge orders justice department to
release redacted affidavit leading to
search of donald trump's mar-a-lago home
i'll put it simply for you guys the
affidavit is mostly redacted we don't we
don't even know half of the stuff in
there is
from the sounds of it
donald trump was in communication donald
trump's people were in communications
with the national archives
they said you have stuff that you took
from the white house that's you know
part of the archives the boxes trump had
15 contained newspaper clippings
magazines personal memos and some memos
and some classified information women's
underwear
perhaps
donald trump's people returned those
boxes
the fbi then said
when they were told by the national
archives they believed that was probable
cause that donald trump still had more
stuff in his house and therefore they
should raid him
they then found 11 stacks like packets
of documents and took them because they
were classified cash patel mentioned the
president declassified these things they
shouldn't have taken them it sounds like
they knew trump had crossfire hurricane
russia gate documents that were going to
potentially implicate or at the very
least besmirch
the name of the fbi
and they need an excuse to go in check
or seize
this sounds
dangerously corrupt and dirty
and uh
i don't i don't know i mean did donald
trump not have copies of whatever these
documents were is he's an old guy so
maybe but
i don't know if i believe there was any
reason that would warrant what they did
at trump's house because he was
cooperating he'd already turned over
these these items yeah that's like if
there was a gun recall and they're like
turning your guns and you're turning
your gun and then they're like hey
that's evidence that you might have more
guns we're gonna see break into your
house and check like what no no no no no
i i i did what you asked i returned the
item maybe you had been a cop if you're
like return your contraband items if
there's like a drug recall return your
cocaine you you return it you get rid of
it like there are societies where
they're like here dispense you there
then they use that as a reason to go
check your that's insanity no i just
think it's unrealistic to think any
government entity asks you to turn in
something like with
like blinders on right they're not they
never granted anyone immunity they asked
him to turn in something and it
immediately gave them cause if you
turned in drug paraphernalia or guns
like of course then they're gonna be
like well we know you have a history of
owning drug paraphernalia or guns like
we're gonna continue down this road how
about that completely fake story about
nuclear documents oh yeah the washington
post was like they were looking for
nuclear documents and then i see all
these leftists and they're like trump
stole 300 nuclear documents and the
rights defending him and then it turns
out the warrant was just like we would
like all documents at any point during
your presidency that you may have it's
like okay well they were looking for
literally anything it's called the
fishing expedition
they gave themselves a broad warrant to
take whatever they wanted
it really does sound like they're scared
that those documents from crossfire
hurricane will get out now i have to
wonder this why didn't trump just
release them if that's the case perhaps
trump was preparing an october surprise
when he was announcing he would be
running for president and then he would
say boom here's the story
maybe i don't know i think it's also
notable like we talked about this a
little bit before but they didn't leak
this i mean trump is the one who
announced the world that they were
raiding his house this was not leaked to
the press beforehand i don't think the
fbi wanted anyone to know this is what
they were doing they wanted to turn off
the surveillance cameras and stuff i
remember yeah they wanted it to be
they wanted to have the element of
surprise and uh you know uh
have this happen clandestinely until
they had decided what they had found to
then tell you about it and again donald
trump kind of interrupted that narrative
by being like no they're at my house
like let's all pay attention to this and
everyone was shocked by it i mean i
don't think anyone had a clear
explanation i think on the left there
was a lot of scrambling to come up with
like a good reason why they would have
done this especially when they knew he
wasn't there that was one of the things
that bothered me that he was it was
known that he was in new jersey because
of a golf tournament at the time they
specifically picked a time when he
wouldn't be there to do this the same
fbi team that oversaw the russia
investigation
raids his house
to take documents that
people are saying was
from the russia investigation
sounds like there's corruption afoot
yeah like they've been um on the track
to start this to transition to a new
world order like
you know
reduce i don't know what they're doing
with the american military bases but
just like from the liberal world order
to the new world order and donald trump
was slowing it down and then so so
behind the scenes they're like we just
don't want him slowing us down but in
public they're like he's a villain so
hate him so that you don't elect him
again no i mean he probably he said he
was going to dismantle a lot of that
stuff anyway in a second term if he ever
got one or something like that that's
right so forward to it there we were
saying that desperation leads to
mistakes and there's no way we can look
at this aside from this was a mistake
they're making moves that suggest that
if they didn't do it they would get
dismantled so we might as well do
something really crazy to try to save
ourselves because if we don't we're
going to lose anyway so there now
they're losing reputation by doing
things like this
i think if they're if we start being
honest with ourselves and each other
that like yeah it's inevitable man we're
globalizing this world is coming
together in a new way it's we're not
going to be the king of the hill
american is
we're never supposed to be like the top
leader ever and we're part of it well
i'm okay with america i mean i'm
ignorant so when i say this take it with
a grain of salt i'm okay with america
just kind of cooling it off a little bit
let's focus on ourselves getting it
together
here for a little while before like it's
like that uh verse not to quote too many
things of like
before you tell your friend hey you've
got a plank in your eye or no take
you've got a speck of dust i've got a
plank in my eye how about america cleans
its own up act up before telling the
rest of the world how to you know
operate themselves and if the rest of
the world wants to drive themselves into
a hole and a socialist nightmare
whatever the downside to that is that we
lose access to resources and you know
our advantage across the planet but
maybe we need to focus on ourselves for
a little while to clean up america has
been acting like
you know as this dude who's got a bunch
of credit card debt
can't pay it off keeps taking out more
loans
instead
and then going around and just yelling
at the neighbors about how they got to
pay up and give them money yeah
it's like me going to your house and
saying i don't like where your furniture
is let me start moving things around but
my house is a mess
well i i think you know just to be a
little bit more specific the us is just
like riddled with debt and then
basically just
printing money behind the scenes to
satiate its addictions
while
criticizing you know it's just they're
either assuming broken system all right
so they're gonna pass on that debt to
the next generation so maybe they're
assuming that the next generation is
going to do really good and we'll be
able to our kids will be able to pay
that bill that's the optimistic way
that's what modern monetary theory is
that you print enough go into deficit
and
that you are able to build enough
industry and infrastructure that the
product starts to outweigh the debt and
eventually you bypass the investiture
is that we haven't been investing it in
industry properly in the last 10 years
that's the lie that's what they want you
to think to make it make sense they want
you to think that no no look we're going
to take out we're gonna deficit spend i
know you're right it's bad but we're
gonna build these factories and it's
gonna make up for it no they always
there always has to be more debt there
always has to be more debt to keep the
machine churning and all they do is it's
like it's a ponzi scheme remember when
obama did that stimulus where he just
basically gave people money it's like
all right everybody give free money then
they did it again they did with cova
it's like everybody here more free money
now they're talking about how disposable
income is so high that people are not
working and i'm like are you kidding me
and now they're doing debt forgiveness
i look at the student debt forgiveness
stuff and i think it's in line with
their policy of
just throwing money at people
and i wonder why that is well i also
think it's part of their policy of we're
going to give you the good headlines
right but joe biden is going to be the i
left afghanistan and canceled student
debt president but
it's a sound bite none of it is real i
mean as you have said before i i it's
more than that they gave free money
unemployment they gave free money uh
bonus checks they they uh deferred
student loans and now they're paying
student loans they're they're doing a
whole bunch of things that basically
just
distribute wealth
to other two to two people what's
monopoly money they're just yeah but
like
they're flooding the system yeah it's
going to cause hyperinflation and
destroy it
it's it feels like it's on purpose when
they announced when body's like i'm
going to cancel student debt it's like
after you already gave all of these
people free money for not working you
deferred their payments gave them
unemployment guarantees with bonuses on
top
and they did not pay their debts but
they didn't have to now their debts are
kicking back in don't worry we delayed
another four months and we're going to
pay down 10 grand of it it's like why
didn't they just use the money they were
getting for free to pay down what they
had to pay down
they just keep throwing money at people
and where's that money coming from your
pocket the federal reserve it's what's
happening is they're getting it from the
federal reserve and then so they'll
borrow a buck from the federal reserve
but then we owe a dollar and one cent
back so where does that one cent come
from federal reserve so now you owe
interest on the money you took out to
pay the interest
that's the ponzi scheme tax money does
go to the federal government they do use
your money and then they deficit spend
by borrowing money and doing fractional
reserve money creation stuff but a lot
of the money that's being distributed is
literally just your tax dollars that
went to the government so the funny
thing is right now
these leftists are like if you forgive
student loan debt you're just erasing
the debt from the books it's like you
are correct but that means the money
that we gave you our money is not coming
back you have taken our money from us
now i'm in favor of getting rid of the
interest rates and trying to alleviate
the student debt problem for sure but uh
taking money from the working class to
pay for the laptop class does not sound
like you know good policy
it's they the more steps that you have
it obscures what you're doing and it
just confuses people like
if i read a headline i'll just read the
headline i'm not going to really look
into it deeply most people are very low
resolution when it comes to reading the
news or even understanding the news i
don't have time to read deeply
that's why i watch the news in the first
place i'll i want the quick
uh
the quick story so i can
quickly understand what's going on and
the more steps they're doing it on
purpose the more steps are involved
john doe you know going to work every
day nine to five he's exhausted he's got
his kids he's got his hobbies he's tired
all the time he doesn't need to be
thinking about all this and some of them
they they package it in such a way that
i'm happy oh minimum wage is now 15
that's great yeah but wait why is milk
now five dollars when it used to be two
dollars well let's never forget the
inflation reduction act i mean joe biden
wants to be the headline president where
he's giving you these like do you
remember all those good things
he doesn't want anyone to look into it
and ultimately he is causing extreme
damage in his wake but he's gonna come
around and be like no no the democrats
are the party of reducing inflation and
like and forgiving this is this is the
one thing that would make me want to run
for office is that if you're in congress
you can come out there and be like i'm
proposing the help the small babies act
save the kitties and what does the bill
do it like takes twenty dollars from
every paycheck so that i can buy my
myself a house like just really
egregiously awful things it'd be like
the bill just basically says tim pool
gets 20 of every american's paycheck and
will be rich but it's called like the
save the dying children act
like why won't you vote for this what's
wrong with you the there was a comic and
it's like the free beer act yeah you see
this one yeah it's like okay so when do
i get a free beer it's like what do you
mean free beer the free beer act just
raises your taxes by two percent yeah
well i call it low resolution versus
high resolution most people i mean i'm
stealing this from peterson sort of but
most people don't have time to
in in graphics terms a high resolution
image takes more time to render
so cpu-wise if i have to read a full
page of text to understand what this
bill is versus just give me the headline
that's the low resolution version but oh
the problem with low resolution is you
lose all the details well and when you
see this with articles it'll have the
big headline that's flashy it'll have
the first couple lines that have
information but any
any information that sort of sways or
gives partisan like if if a publication
wants you to have a certain view on an
issue they put it in the top third of
the article because that's as bad as far
as you're going to read and all the
nuance details are in the bottom two bad
news is in the right anything that may
contradict their claims and that's
because they know
that people won't read that far they
just i mean there's so much media and so
much information coming out at all times
right now it's actually very difficult
to stay well informed on everything so i
can't really fault the general public
for that but it is how the human mind
works right it's the easiest way to sway
someone but they're playing they're
playing the game in such a way that like
democrats i'll give them credit for this
most people don't have time to think
about things this deeply the average
person you can call them stupid but
actually they're just busy probably
that's why with i mean not to toot my
own horn too much well that's why comics
works so well is because they say like
you know a picture is worth a thousand
words let's say
but my comics have four panels so the my
1 000 words yeah wow so it's like a zip
file i don't remember if i've told said
this before a comic is like a zip file
it's cross referencing with like
hyperlinks that you already made
you might have read a story about this
now you're seeing four images that are
related to that story but now you're
thinking about other things that these
images are now recalling memories from
your memory and you're now filling in
the blanks so my four images are now
giving you a full essay in the span of
five seconds maybe less that's why
images are so powerful and that's why
headlines are powerful and that's why
twitter i've said this forever twitter
is comics it's just every tweet is like
a panel you're scrolling you're
scrolling
you're getting maybe an image that's why
i will often attach an image to my
tweets because it makes you stop
scrolling what's this image it's very
shocking to look at when i worked
real quick we pulled this uh uh this
panel up this comic from george
we have this comic hanging on our wall
it's right to the left of george
actually you can't see it but it's joe
biden and he says it is estimated that
by that 200 it is estimated that 200
million people will die by the time i
finish that talk and that time is now
and then he fires force lightning from
his hands and just electrocutes everyone
in the crowd it's hilarious and they're
like their eyes are glowing and there's
lightning everywhere this is like a
misspeak of biden too he literally said
this yeah he literally said he didn't
say this time is now no i know but
that's the point like people who see
this are going to be like what's this
about yeah and then someone's going to
say like that first panel is an actual
quote from you he was talking about kova
deaths i believe he accidentally said
200 million when he meant what 200 000
no no what he meant was
he said it is estimate what he meant to
say was it is estimated that by the time
i finish this talk there will be yeah no
you're right he's going to say by the
time i finish talk x amount of people
will have died but it was like only 200
000 or something it was a lower number
but he said 200 million
he said will die
not will have died oh god so so all his
catches are wrong
but i just love how he just the the last
panel of the guy screaming with like
he's like ah it's being electrocuted by
biden's force lightning so what we're
doing is as we're scrolling let's say i
see this in my twitter
nobody ever thinks about this but it's
what comics is
i'm scrolling i'm scrolling i see
someone getting electrocuted i laugh i'm
now bypassing all the firewalls and
you're like
i don't remember what the
frontal cortex is i'm going straight to
your amygdala i'm going into your deep
brain you're laughing you don't even
know why yet now you're reading and now
you're downloading that zip file that i
gave you and it says valor margulis on
his uh harrisburg
i don't know the neurology about
laughter and how it affects same with
crying and and fear if i go boo you're
you're not thinking oh i'm going to be
scared it's just a reflex this is this
this plays into what we were talking
about earlier with why you know we're
doing music we're trying like creating
funny relatable or entertaining spaces
that's what the arts are this is what
regular people associate with this is
what i was explaining earlier on one of
my segments when i was shouting out the
song we did
when i used to do non-profit fundraising
if if you saw somebody like ian in the
street and you walked up to him and went
excuse me search his moment of your time
and shook his hand and said i got a
proposal for you right now he'd be like
bro what what are you talking about you
got to walk up to someone like ian and
go bro
high five and be like listen here bro
you wanna save the trees right every day
you gotta talk to you you have to meet
people where they are relatable you
can't walk up to a guy in a suit looking
like ian and then being like bruh you
wanna save some trees i'm gonna be back
i'm busy i have no idea you gotta walk
up to the guy who's a no-nonsense guy
and be no nonsense listen i'll get five
seconds we gotta save trees i need you
to pitch in you're gonna do it check my
hand buddy they you you have to meet
people where they are to the left
if you go to someone with a maga hat on
and a trump flag and start saying listen
you need to understand donald trump
donald and joe biden they're going to be
like i have no idea who you are i don't
know what you're on about and i this is
confusing to me but if you approach them
from where they are you know you notice
that they've got like a cubs hat you
could be like cubs what up man you're
from chicago be like oh i got family
from chicago meet them where they are
open a conversation and then find out
where you can you can come together and
you can share those important ideas
that's what art does people will see
this and whether you're political or not
it's funny joe biden's electrocuting a
bunch of people it opens the door it can
stimulate things like empathy here's a
story that maybe you wouldn't have been
open to
the message of the story but i have told
it in such a way that now you're
oh yeah i do relate to those characters
i do feel bad for them or i do feel what
they're feeling and now i'm starting to
think the way they are i relate to joe
biden here wanting to use force
lightning to vaporize 200 million
i think we have this illusion that
people are more politically engaged
because politics has seeped into so much
of our culture it's in our pop it's in
our popular culture it's uh blood into
art we we hear about a lot and i think
that's true even of people who don't
work in my field uh but actually most
people
aren't that interested they do like
comics they like things that are more
accessible to them so i think you're
totally right that having something if i
if i were to send someone a cnn headline
or a fox news headline you know they
might already have their guard up
whereas art or something that they're
interested in on a medium that they're
already scrolling through twitter is
much more accessible and also more
enjoyable because they don't feel like
they're going to be immediately sorted
into some sort of category the news a
lot of the time is very dry and i i just
don't want to download all this
information but if i'm online scrolling
maybe i'm on the toilet or something i'm
on the bus i just want to be entertained
i want to laugh i want to smile i want
to see something interesting i want to
be entertained when i'm on the toilet
that's right you know i used to have
these things called bathroom readers
that were like at my house and they're
just books full of random trivia yeah
that you're like you're supposed to read
when you're taking a dump yeah i got one
of my bathrooms says what uh what is
your poo telling you is the name of the
book okay well that's not what i was
hopeful the book i read was just like it
was called the bathroom reader and it
had on the bottom of every page a
factoid and then it had chapters of like
random stories and legends and facts and
it just filled my brain up with random
nonsense is that why you know the name
of that law
well that's that's a journalism thing
you know i hate i i despise the
corporate press so much that i've like
yes how can i criticize them today what
do you guys think about removing titles
from bills
just having them numbered
i think we get too confusing i think
bills should be chopped up into the
individual things that they're trying to
pass and not turned into omnibuses yeah
yeah the confederates had that didn't
they did yeah this is actually really
interesting they had something that said
something like it has to be a really
short summary one page something like
that
one issue can address one issue exactly
but then what they know they can't uh
inject all their stupid crap in there
because you could even with one section
of a bill you could still call it the
happy lucky bill and then all about you
give me a hundred bucks it's a bill
called like the saving ian and helping
him live a happy life bill but the bill
calls for the imprisonment for me to
chop wood all day yeah i like to be in
prison and that's like well because we
think that'll be good for him yeah yeah
you think you're helping i don't like
the names they're very manipulative oh
the patriot act come on oh yeah it's
garbage and people fall for it there was
one more thing i wanted to add on that
subject too is
the fact that the left has annexed all
of the arts it was not an accident they
know that people are bored of news
the only way to it's like inception to
give you
the thoughts that i want to give you i'm
going to tell you a story or a parable
so they will spend millions and billions
of dollars
creating movies writing stories uh
songs anything related to the arts and
that's why they've taken over all of the
arts i'm not joking they've taken over
all of the arts because that's how you
can persuade people without even
they don't even know it and they know
that it's much harder to convince
someone who does know to invest in those
spaces what do you see across the board
among those who are aware of what's
going on everything they do is political
this is this is what frustrates me we
get a bunch of really great songs
and i don't think it's bad you know the
top-ranking songs overtly political
fjb like three different fjb songs
reached up okay that's still a net
positive because regular people will see
like how come the top songs are fjb but
they're not going to convince most
people it does create some awareness
people who are aware red pilled whatever
they call it
you're it's harder to convince them to
say like hey subscribe to a a children's
channel that's like family education
content because they're going to be like
how is this engaging in in the battle to
to fight against these ideas
because it seems counter-intuitive but
it's exactly what the left has been
doing to the tune of hundreds of
billions of dollars for decades maybe a
century over century i mean they did it
to hollywood they're doing it with music
i mean when we were kids they were
always talking in church about oh all
this music's all about sex all the time
but we are now seeing what happens when
culture is hypersexualizing young people
let's say we're seeing what happens when
that is unchecked we don't know
like i love manga for instance if i go
to the manga section like a lot of young
people love it and stuff but those
stories are actually a lot of them
can be pretty raunchy and like super
rated you know x and stuff like that
i could go to a local library i was
telling a young person in my life hey
you should go to the library and read
these mangas but definitely don't read
these ones i can't stop them from doing
that but
when they have access to entertainment
that is let's say
let's say there's an agenda to push
certain subjects on young people
especially because when they grow up
they will be more permissive towards
these subjects
the parents don't even know what these
kids have access to no they don't i also
think the art used to be a polite way
like impolite culture you wouldn't
discuss politics or anything too
controversial so you talk about art you
talk about what's going on and that was
an easy way for
certain ideologies to route into daily
conversations they just jumped around it
and because things are more blurred and
because we have so many um you know i'm
thinking like celebrities who come out
with these big public statements about
their political beliefs uh
it's actually not the perfect escape
route it once was and i think it's
waking conservatives up to the fact that
like they abandoned this space before
they even knew they could use it i mean
what's that what was the number one song
right now you looked at it oh yeah i
have it pulled up
um
super freaky girl by nicki minaj okay i
wonder what that's about i don't say i i
don't know but it sounds like looking
pretty sexy in that picture that's what
remember when ben shapiro wrapped that
famous song
[ __ ] yeah and it actually was really
funny because he like read the lyrics
and then someone took him reading and
put it over the song actually really
funny yeah but um
do you wonder why it is that when you
look at the tops like the top tracks so
often the songs are like not appropriate
for kids or that you actually have some
artists that gloat and laugh at the idea
that your kids listen to the horrible
things they're talking about in this
music
dude don't ask me why but the wright
abandoned this space a long time ago and
it probably has something to do with
telling telling kids like you don't want
to be a musician that's a waste of a
career like you need to grow up and be a
doctor or run a business
they don't think that art the arts and
i've been trying to convince them for
the longest time the arts are not a good
investment they might say but there's
that saying of
politics or downstream from culture
when
most young people who have more time
than anybody else to consume media or
anything like that
watch movies uh anything music
they have access to
anything that you want to put into their
brains without any supervision
whatsoever
yeah i think conservatives ensemble too
uh reward seriousness or what they
perceive as seriousness and so often
when you're interested in creative
activities it's like well unless you can
prove to me that you can make money off
this right away you know it's it's a
it's something you do on the side and
you're enjoying the fun whereas like
uh
you know a credit to my friends who grew
up in really liberal households their
parents when they were passionate about
something did take basically everything
seriously uh and you know there are pros
and cons to both approaches but i think
that leaves the door open to people
feeling like your art is incredibly
important you have to pursue it to to
the point where it becomes influential
whereas you know often
the other the other approach is to say
like
wait until you have the funds to finance
your life as an artist
when i when i was younger the the
liberals in where i grew up were
basically saying you can do whatever you
want to do
dream dream big
you can you know you want to be an actor
you want to play video games whatever it
is you want to do the conservatives in
my life were much more like just work
hard get a good job and make money
and there's no fun in there
but you get a lot of people so i know i
i there are people that i knew that were
very much into the arts when they were
younger but they had very conservative
parents you know i went to catholic
school for a little bit and where are
they now
they have family they have some kids and
and really it really i'm they're very
happy good for them i'm i'm glad that
they're you know they're leading a good
life and they're doing right by their
kids but this also means that many of
these kids did not pursue the arts that
they were involved in and thus the
people who did and
why they all do drugs all the time where
is it you know that where are the rock
stars who are just like oh man i'm sober
i don't want to do any of that stuff i'm
just about living a good life and being
doing right by my friends and family in
my community that's like a rare thing to
hear in like celebrity culture in
hollywood they're doing drugs they're
like
you know just
raunchy you get it yeah have you ever
seen them sorry have you ever seen the
documentary the other f word it's about
these punk rockers who like become
fathers and kind of what their is it's
it's really good uh and a lot of them
talk about there's one in particular who
talks about like being on tour all the
time and like partying and the culture
that comes with that he's like but the
thing is like when you have kids like
you may be up until 4am do drugs doing
whatever but like your baby's gonna be
up at six and you you have to get up
with it and so it's a shift in mindset
and i think that
uh
it is one of the challenges of being an
artist or you know a lot of careers have
this but like you have to sacrifice when
you have other demands in your life and
i think a lot of
especially popular left-leaning artists
now don't have those kind of
responsibilities because they defer
becoming parents and so they can
continue to pursue this path and push
the ideology i i want to say the right
is learning but i don't know if that's
the really what's happening i think
what's happening is there are liberals
who are joining the right
that people who are used to be into the
arts and fairly left-leaning who are
either forced out or who who saw how
crazy the left was getting and moved out
so
there there's um
this this movie coming out my son hunter
is that what it is my son hunter i think
it's called
and um
the dude who put it together i think
he's the guy from goonies right
i'm not sure that's what you told me uh
robert davey yeah that's all i know what
you told me yeah from goodies so i'm
thinking what's happening is that there
are people who had the skills and know
how to make this content
start realizing how crazy things are
getting and are bringing that art and
culture to the right
and the right needs to support and
embrace it like like the daily wire they
get it
they've repeatedly said
that we're not making political stuff
we're just making shows and movies and
they're buying movies because they get
it i think jeremy all those guys man
mike michael jeremy um they're an
example of like
perceptive tolerance uh
i'm not on the left i mean i was like i
guess you'd say a leftist i was a
liberal like wacky zany artist my whole
life and i just left because it was like
don't tell me i have white privilege you
know you got to use better words than
that if you want to communicate with me
but i'm not going to be sitting told
that i'm a i'm an evil i'm a demon i'm
not living that way
uh so i disassociated from those people
but people like jeremy doesn't like he
just loves people you know he just likes
cool people they hired a disney
executive yeah to be their chief
marketing officer that means that this
disney executive now reports to a man
who goes to church on sunday fascinating
that's seriously taken over the space
and taking it away from them so i hope
they can continue to grow and expand
because the daily wire really needs
those smart tv apps i know we do too
but i can just say like with the amount
of resources they have
you know they're going to get there
before we do but we've been having a
bunch of meetings about getting our
mobile apps and our tv app so that you
can watch what shows we have uh as soon
as possible you know on your tv i'm glad
you brought up drugs earlier i think
that that's an important part of art and
culture and has been since the dawn of
humanity and uh part of why there's a
stagnancy in the industry right now is
from all the pharmaceutical drugs that
have taken the place of thc which has
been illegal for a hundred years for
stupid you know what anslinger made it
illegal with that what was that william
randolph-hearst printing all his
propaganda to make wheat illegal because
he owned all the paper mills and he
didn't want hemp newspapers anymore he
wanted
paper newspapers uh so they they like
colluded and then got weed made illegal
and now they're
you know we had the resurgence with the
lsd thing in the 60s and you saw the
beatles elvis i mean he was coked out of
i don't know what drugs elvis was on but
i know he's on a lot of them and all the
amazing beautiful art created in the 60s
and 70s was like part of the drug
revolution well part of the
the allure of drugs i mean i'm speaking
as an artist in air quotes i don't drink
i don't do drugs or anything like that
but i'm still very much
i understand that the whole point of
drugs to these people is to expand your
mind make the world more interesting
like see the truth behind you know
people talk about dmt and all that stuff
and i hear i'm interested in the stories
i'm not going to do it myself but the
whole idea is creating uh you could say
there's that personality trait openness
and all that stuff
openness to new experiences and
generally the right is not super open to
new experiences because their position
is that
life is good enough why change things
but by our nature artists are explorers
and we need to be able to go to places
that are forbidden
uh even if it's like illegal if i'm
gonna smoke some whatever because i want
to see what happens because
i don't want to be stagnant that's where
you get that term rolling stone which is
ironic because now the left is now the
stagnant
side of things and the rolling stone
which gathers no moss is now the right
we're looking for a new way to move into
the next century it's the problem
and why a lot of artists fail is because
of the over exploration and the
obsessiveness with drugs like they don't
know when to put it down you need
balance well you have to be able to set
it aside to create business if you want
to be a successful artist you mentioned
uh illegality and there's a few very
important things about this i talk about
quite a bit the law doesn't matter as
much as the culture does there are many
things that are overtly illegal that our
culture permits and completely is in
movies
is totally it's considered totally fine
i started watching breaking bad
i've cause i never actually watched i've
only watched parts of it and it's funny
how in the first season walter white who
has these main characters got lung
cancer so he's like he claims to be
smoking pot and they're all shocked by
it it's like that's so weird because you
go to any major city even before
decriminalization and legalization
everybody
it was like movies talked about it look
at the movie half to bake half baked
with dave chappelle
a movie outright about a bunch of
stoners
like that movie is literally a cultural
icon and it's about a bunch of dudes
committing repeated felonies like it's a
crazy idea if you think about it i
thought breaking bad was uh
cancer propaganda like the cancer
industry propaganda because in the show
he's always like i need to get the
treatment and the ideas if he ever gets
the treatment the cancer will be gone
you watched it i watched like eight
episodes like you watched it yeah i
watched something because the first
treatment he's like i refuse i won't use
it i wanna get then he's like i need to
get the treatment his wife's like you
gotta get the treatment it's all about
the treatment he couldn't afford it and
then
all of a sudden
that's true but i just want to say like
i'm only on like episode seven and a lot
of people probably know more but he
outright says to her i will not spend
the rest of my days lying there
listlessly gagging i won't do it well
the premise of the first season spoiler
i guess alert is that he's trying to get
money to pay for the cancer treatment
that's the kind of the premise of the
show and what leads him into the drug
industry i i
i don't think that's that's true that's
why he's making meth is to get
money you watch the cancer treatment he
turns down free money
yeah yeah but he's you know his wife
wants him to get the treatment and then
his his colleague says i'll pay for
everything he says no
and it's more so about he breaks free
from
he he's like i'm awake now and that's in
like episode two
his business partner comes and says
don't worry everything's covered and he
goes
no
he rejects it and then says i don't want
the treatment i will not spend my last
days lying in bed as a burden to you i
won't do it then she convinced him to do
it and then it's sort of about how he's
he wants this money but he gets way like
instantly he gets way more money than he
needs i don't think the show is about
him
uh i'm again i'm only on like episode
seven
but it's like
uh right away before he's even doing the
drug dealing he's talking about how good
he feels breaking the law and then he
bangs his wife outside of a of a school
meeting and she's like why was it so
good it was because it was illegal
it's not he doesn't need the money i
think that was the point they were
trying to make no he needs the treatment
he takes okay okay we're being told that
he needs to really if we're looking at
treatment then it will be cured as well
i can only have to write his two
characters though he's not just walter
wright he's also heisenberg so you're
looking at the carl young thing of the
man versus his shadow and who eventually
takes over
i don't want to spoil anything but
it's really
you've got the
milk toast whatever the walter white is
you know fairly timid and then the
heisenberg comes out of him
in the later seasons as he becomes more
aggressive and he finds people who test
him he essentially has to put walter
white away and become this other person
in order to survive because now in the
first season he's fighting cancer but in
the future seasons he's fighting people
who are not only threatening his life
but people around him so i'm again like
i'm only in the beginning seasons but
it's very obvious from the very first
episodes that what's driving him is the
exhilaration he gets from being put in
these he's like he's a adrenaline rush
that's the heisenberg character starting
to emerge that's an interesting thing
it's the symbol of i'm embracing my
shadow is taking over me now i saw this
episode when it first aired the
fulminated mercury episode
and
it's just so good have you seen that one
he goes to tuco
and then he's like he goes tight tight
he goes walk up and he's he's like i
want fifty thousand dollars and then he
starts laughing it's like 35 for the
matthews stolen 15 for my partner's you
know uh paying suffering
and then tuko laughs and he's like you
come here you make demands you bring
more meth and he's like he grabs it it's
not meth and then he throws it it
explodes
when he gets back in the car he goes
yeah yeah it was very much about him
that's walter white powerful yeah he's
not he's not walter white anymore but
but anyway my point was actually called
white that the name is white like white
light yeah i'm sure that's um my point
was just that
a lot of people claim the show is about
a guy who's dying of cancer and needs
money for a treatment but no no not that
the whole show's about that i'm just
saying that insidious message was in
there i thought but it's not well it was
in the first season for sure no
that's the purpose that's why he got
into the whole thing to begin that was
the inciting incident was he got cancer
they needed to get an expensive cancer
treatment where am i going to get the
money he didn't want the treatment he
refused it but his wife wanted it
because we were being told and and
walter was born before that happened
because i don't think he's in denial
like you know i'm just confused i i i
did you watch it or not because i
watched eight about seven eight or eight
episodes because i literally watched i'm
watching it last night and correct if
i'm wrong guys but he goes to his
partner's house and he says i will pay
for everything and walter says no
and then he tells his family in the next
heisenberg talking but then in the next
scene he says i'm not going to live this
way
it he does he doesn't need to sell meth
to pay for the treatment the point was
he was choosing to be to to
he was exhilarated by being this bad guy
that happens yeah but in like the first
three episodes he's not he's like a
humble weak guy and he's like i'm scared
and his wife's like i'm scared get the
money we need money we need money you
need the treatment these people that's
so much because i know chemo can destroy
bodies
i'm pretty sure the entire reason he
started collecting money was not for the
treatment was but to give his family
money so like yeah that's what i i've
never seen i've only seen a couple
episodes but that's what i thought it
was i thought he wanted to be able to
like he didn't want to go out like you
know chemo was really demanding on the
body he didn't want to be suffering and
like kind of undignified and he
i could be totally wrong i remember how
many kids he has but like he wanted to
leave them with something and that is
goes into like well
if i know that i'm ultimately going to
die like what do i have to do oh yeah
that was another thing like that's the
first answer was they were acting like
cancer was a death sentence i don't like
that propaganda okay well it's really a
study of what would you do if you were
in this situation so so he has stage
three lung cancer or something too much
cheese metastasized perhaps
and i think like the first episode his
motivation for selling the drugs was
because he wanted to give his family
money
and then when he died they'd have
something not that he wanted to save
himself when his partner offers to pay
for it all he says no i don't want it
and then he goes and he walks out with a
bag of 50 grand he's
now he's doing it because it's making
him feel good but i don't think it would
i i he he ends up starting to get the
treatment because his wife begs him to
do it but it was the he he had the money
and then i i didn't watch this far but i
don't want to i don't want to spoil any
more of it
all right so the reason the whole show
is popular anyway why why do people love
the anti-hero archetype so much the idea
of becoming
there are things that we can do all of
us that are dark and
cruel and wrong that would benefit us in
the short term but why don't we do it
because we live in a society it would be
wrong to do it but what happens if
someone gets pushed how can you
it that's why the show's popular it asks
you what would have to happen to you to
push you beyond the point where it's
like i don't care if this is wrong
anymore i'm gonna do
whatever it takes to get mine but then
the show also i think it dropped the
ball in later seasons it doesn't ask
what are the consequences of all the
things like how does it affect all the
people that you victimized let's say
we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already instead of debating
breaking bad uh if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and share the
show with your friends head over to
timcast.com become a member but also
it would be a great help to us if you
would click the link in the description
below and purchase the song only ever
wanted 69 cents it is it is it is cost
effective and easy to get and we
actually don't need that much to act to
have an impact in the in the music space
i think that uh you know if everybody
watched spent that 69 cents a good
number right elon musk would love it
then uh we would force these
institutions to recognize that you know
we can make moves in this space and at
the very least let them retreat from it
tom mcdonald has been absolutely
destroying the music industry in a way
that they're forced to write articles
about him and they're they're like is
conservative rep a thing and it's like
oh surprise surprise i don't even think
that dude's a conservative i think he's
just pointing out y'all are nuts and
it's working
but
christian metal is a thing
christian metal but it's it's not about
i think it's not like look if you want
really effective christian music look at
creed they were they were big christians
weren't they they were i have heard that
yes but they wrote songs that appealed
to regular people
it's almost like christians are people
yeah
if you write a song where you outright
like you know raise your hands and
praise praise the lord that's that
doesn't no nobody can relate to it
that's not already doing that but if you
say arms wide open i welcome you to this
world or whatever or just write a love
song exactly yeah all right ready to
rumble says tim literally paid hundreds
of thousands of dollars to get people to
play with him in a band i did not nearly
spend that much money but um we're
putting it where we're investing heavily
maybe i should do like an announcement
like daily wire didn't be like we're
dedicating x you know amount of dollars
towards for the record i played music
with tim before he ever paid me any
money yeah and it's just the company
that pays us both and we're
actually so that way like we are paying
a lot of money to get people to to play
music but uh we're going to be producing
other people's music at our cost
so it's like
you know ian's got songs he's going to
record that or his own thing that we are
paying for him to do you guys are so
amazing ian's got a really good song
what's that song that i really frequent
measure and there's versions of it on
youtube check out if you want to hear
but i i can't wait to do it with pete on
drums i'm the guy's a maniac justin
justin says bro good song gave me
goosebumps thank you i really really do
appreciate it
paul thongkam says listen to the new
single it was good then see you're sung
it for 69 cents i see what you did there
we didn't do anything you get three
options 69 cents 99 cents or 1.29 and of
course what we want is maximum sales
we're less concerned about making a
bunch of money off the music but that's
the lowest you can sell it for so 420.
that's a lot to sell a song for you
people are crazy and they would do it
yeah yeah there you go so uh
when when because we're in the era of
streaming and no longer purchasing
purchasing is 150 times that of a stream
so it's like 69 cents is the equivalent
of listening to the song 150 times jeez
which is just like massively powerful
we can do 10 songs at 69 cents each or
get the album for four dollars and 20
cents do you ever that's a good idea
yeah do you guys consider doing physical
copies like science and stuff we're
going to do vinyl send them goodies yeah
i want to do vinyls cool cover signup
laser etched yeah all sorts of cool like
we're gonna get we're getting a machine
to print our own vinyls nice yeah so you
can uh you can record yourself
you can go in and press record and it'll
scratch the vinyl in real time and it
goes for like two and a half minutes i
think but then we can also put
you know we can't put this song's four
and a half minutes long so you know
all right
prefer rumble says when we live in a
time where definitions are changed and
truth is ignored in order to steer the
narrative how do we present the truth in
ways to bust the narrative any tips for
breaking the ice
i will tell you this as i was saying
earlier you have to meet people where
they are you can't expect them to come
to where you are so breaking the ice is
actually simple
the first step towards making friends
and influencing people is rapport
meaning find a way that you and someone
else can connect
that's that's the easiest way to do it
when i used to do fundraising it was it
was actually really easy you'd see
somebody wearing a band t-shirt and
whatever the band was you would just oh
man you're wearing a metallic uh
metallica bro i used to enter sandman
was like the second song i ever learned
how to play oh what a good song that's
that's true though
i was a little kid and i was like i
could play that it was it was like easy
enough but cool enough i was really
excited and i was like yeah look i can
play this song but you meet you see
someone you open with that and you build
rapport like hey look we share this in
common you know we are people we are
together that's how you break the ice
once you have
once you have a rapport with people now
they're willing to listen because they
they feel that you're operating in good
faith so there are a lot of people i
know who are like on the left and they
might say nasty things to me but i only
respond with nice things and support for
their work and it opens the door and
then we can have that conversation and i
can't change their minds and convince
them overnight that some of these ideas
are crazy but i can show them news
articles which will show them you know
maybe i was wrong about that at least a
little bit
yeah i get the uh whenever someone says
something that i'm relating to like say
we have dinner and we're talking about
it they say something i don't agree with
rather than say no i won't i do not
i do not negate what they're saying i'll
say interesting
and then maybe offer some other idea i
think the other thing is like if people
start saying like don't stay quiet you
don't have to argue but like if someone
is like oh i really believe this you can
ask them more about it and be honest
about how you feel about it i think so
often people are afraid of conflict that
they just don't say like well i don't i
don't see it that way yeah a lot of
conversation is i mean if you think of
two cities trying to interact with each
other if you come at someone with your
shield up and they put their shield up
there's not going to be a lot of
exchange of hey let's shake hands now
they're going to be they're going to
have their firewalls up so
let's say you got two cities that are
trading a little bit you get to know
each other you trust each other so when
you make friends you're really just
trying to
like i don't know you guys ultra well
but the more time i spend with you the
more i like you the more maybe i'll open
up
initially when i first met you guys my
defenses were up i was scared you know
we actually fought we boxed it was
intense yeah do you suggest i remember
friendly the first time i i came here uh
maybe a year or something ago i remember
i was asking hey should i wear a mask
and the first thing i think you asked me
uh was uh do you think all people are
the same or something like do you think
some people are better than others i'm
like
nice to meet you tim that's my i like
your show right so it was very shocking
to me so it put my guard up and then you
know hours and hours of talking later
it's like okay now i'm relaxed it was
fine just it was so when you meet new
people for the first time you have to
sort of
feel their frequency and then adjust
your frequency and now you're talking to
each other yeah when he came up to the
studio he actually went to the corner
and called him into a little ball yeah
and then we started crying
yeah we've way to coax them out well
they showed me the chickens and
george it's your you drew this
all right sarah gent says i love your
new song has anyone ever told you that
you sound like chester bennington
somebody said that last night i've never
heard that until now
i will add
singing this song
it was extremely difficult because the
way i wrote it was more singer
songwriter folk and then carter produced
and engineered it in a way that i had
not initially written it which required
me to sing in a way i don't normally do
but i really love when people are like i
can't that's not really tim sing this
it's literally me
and um for a lot of people are like how
did he pull that off i had to sing this
one like 30 times it was it was nuts
like i had to go into the studio with
carter like 30 times and keep trying it
and trying it and missing and missing
because it is just not my normal range
but we have a couple songs it's not so
much that's on my normal range but the
better way to put it is
i can do it i am not practiced in this
style of falsetto switching breathy
higher
so uh i don't think i would normally
ever sound like chester bennington when
i'm singing my other songs but listen to
will of the people and maybe i don't
know tell me what you think
i think what they're experiencing when
they hear you sing the haters it's like
an uncanny valley thing like you're the
news guy but wait he also it's like when
you see your teacher at the grocery
store yeah wait you have other hobbies
that's weird i don't like it i'm scared
you know what's really funny is uh
when you look at the so i have i use vid
iq and it shows me on a youtube video
whenever something is posted to reddit
you can just click it and it shows you
all the reddit posts so i can see and
i'm like i'm commenting on people on
reddit they're smack talking and they're
they're saying like bald move tim
writing a song like this and it's like
it's funny jokes whatever and i'm just
like i don't care you can rag on me and
uh but it's funny how
there it's like we got half a million
views in the song in a day
and it's overwhelming thumbs up we're
getting hit up by a ton of people we
we've been getting up by like major
label uh affiliated companies and
artists that are like this is really
good stuff
and
what people got to understand that
releasing a song and getting half a
million hits right away is kind of a big
deal it's not like you're going to be
like one of these big artists or
whatever but the left is attacking it
and it really does show how isolated
they are because it's like listen dude
if you come out and start laughing and
pointing and saying huh look everyone
look how dumb it is and they're all
sitting there being like actually we
kind of like it it kind of shows the
emperor has no clothes honestly if i
hear a song i don't like i don't say
anything about it i don't turn it off
and i don't listen to it i definitely
wouldn't comment on a youtube video
about it it's a strange amount of effort
to go out of your way to be like i
really don't like this
it's just okay there's that saying like
the opposite of love isn't hate it's
indifference yeah so if i really like
i'm not going to go up to somebody and
say hey i don't think you're attractive
i don't like you
i bet if you know because the ethan
klein people are posting it on a
subreddit i don't think ethan klein
would hate the song i don't think he's
going to sit there and be like haha
because i don't like tim pool this song
is stupid the destiny subreddit they're
actually like actually it's not that bad
they're like good job beanie boy and i'm
like that's like these people have an
honest approach to it you know they
don't have to like me or agree with me
but i i think a lot of these these
lefties if they actually listen to it
would be like yeah you know it's a
pretty good song it's whatever i don't
expect them to like the genre or
anything like that but it's like a
well-produced thing they just want you
to stay in your box they want you to not
be able to touch the arts yeah
rulers of star says you see that cover
by some black guy it's hot love you love
your one too good job mr banks um
i i saw it i didn't listen to it but uh
i'd love to have him on the show it'd be
great we can we can talk about it
all right
jerkwad says i think the world economic
forum wants to rule the world but brix
also wants the same the two are clashing
with one another lucky for us they suck
at it i think the world economic forum
wants to control the world and bricks
formed because of it partly because of
it to resist the the axises of of you
know nato or whatever
yeah it seems like that's true all right
what do we got here
just a lot of uh we initially got a
whole bunch of super chats i really do
appreciate everybody super chatting
about the song because you know it's
great
and uh just gotta get those sales
fleeting floating feathers says have
amazon prime but purchased the mp3 i've
only ever wanted for 69 cents to show my
support
great song waiting patiently for bright
eyes to drop there's actually a small
snippet of bright eyes on my instagram
and it's like a lot and that was from
months and months ago because the song's
been done for a while but we're just
plotting out our release dates the next
song that's being released is gonna be
right before the midterms i believe and
it's an overtly political song
more
rock
kind of punky in a certain sense but not
really and it's just overtly political
it's about the institutions and uh
sounds pretty good very simple fun
upbeat
but kind of brutal got kind of a do-op
flair you think yeah yeah it's like it's
like it's like um
like rock doo op or something the
working title is genocide
and you know everyone i talk to that
does marketing they're like
they're like please stop maybe no
and i'm like it doesn't need to be
called that because the song is about
institutions that's just what we the
working title of it so maybe we'll think
of something else
all right
let's grab some super church
nobody special says i'm getting used to
ian commenting on a subject he knows
almost nothing about and finding some
way of making a conspiracy of elite
corruption you're getting used to it
i don't know what that refers to because
it's been too long maybe breaking bad oh
probably maybe the catholic church
breaking bad there have been so many
tonight yeah those are the two big ones
tonight i want to see like a web of all
of ian's like conspiracy theories my
brother do something this youtube video
it's like nine hours of like all the
conspiracy theories ever it like reminds
me of whoa we are going to be launching
a conspiracy show
so um
tales from the inverted world initially
we wanted to be like a weekly
exploration but it turned into something
bigger but uh shane is going to be
launching a
call-in show and like weekly
paranormal but skeptics you know podcast
do the graphic where it shows the
conspiracy is connected to each other on
the board but then it's an airplane that
flies from conspiracy to conspiracy and
when it lands it like that's when the
show begins about that one so funny
perhaps
colin cooper says to everyone in the
room thank you now tim answer all three
when is crowder desantis and trump
happening on irl
um all three of them are welcome on the
show at any point for trump we'd have to
go to him for santa's probably the same
and i think crowder is gonna be passing
through the area actually yeah he's
gonna be uh in baltimore this winter i
think we just need to coordinate it if
he's not too busy
gotta figure that one out yeah jimmy
dore's heading this way too and that
might happen because jimmy is awesome
uh jor and he says george sensei i still
have hope i will wait patiently for the
tim's civil war pool comic i wonder if i
don't know if i've told this to anybody
i have a comic of you in doing the civil
war thing oh you do i don't know how you
would know this you didn't post it no i
was gonna do one
did i never say this um so i have a joke
where i have this little stupid whistle
like it's a
so i'll hear like your show and in my
head every time you say civil war
so
first whatever reason i connected the
dots of um you got your chickens in the
back or something some chicken takes a
poop and it's like you go over to it
like a hunter and you
put your finger on as you go
civil war
but i don't think
i never told anyone that one that's
great i didn't do it because i don't
want to be disrespectful without like
telling you i just remember the one from
his birthday where he's being like
beamed up the ufos yeah
yeah i don't want to you know i don't
want to make strips about people without
their permission though it's like no i
don't care so well you know it's respect
it's important you didn't have joe biden
for permission yes well
yeah cliff you didn't ask for um yeah
okay cliff the alien is a good one
i didn't say it cliff the alien says ian
there was a peaceful revolution it was
called ska in the 1990s it was the
happiest sound your planet ever heard
but the next day they made it illegal
and now look at the mess you're in
that's a good point now that is some
very high praise for ska i approve the
musical genre
yes well i guess it started in jamaica
in the 1950s but uh
there's some great stuff did you ever
watch people skank
no it was scar dancing and it was very
silly but you know what i was a huge
mighty mighty boss tones fan i still am
is that scott dicky barrett uh pete's
actually working i don't know if that's
uh that they were mighty mighty boss
tones
i mean they were like a blend of rock
and ska
ska rock i guess you would call it
um i'm telling you 90 real big fish was
pretty good got into those guys 90s
music is going to come back it's the
grunge it's the emo because grunge is
emo grunge was the inception
alternative dude blink 182 kind of
turned it a little more electronic yeah
alternative was also like it's gonna be
like smashing pumpkins you're gonna hear
like semi-sonic eve six those bands new
well i don't know about newfoundland
that's 2000's
it was that 90s rock sound you know that
this is radio girl and vertical verizon
and stuff like that oh yes you know what
i'm saying
i'll tell you why it's going to come
back to me straight because it always
does
like
there's a period where people are like
oh that's old music and then a couple
decades later they're like oh cool retro
classic music and they want to revive it
now we've got kate bush
in the billboard hot 100 number five for
like the past three months running up
that hill it's the 80s getting up to the
90s in a few years people are gonna be
young kids are gonna be like i was born
in the wrong decade yeah i love eve well
i feel like they're like that little bit
uh y2k fashion is like such a big deal
with with zoomers right now and so i
feel like why wouldn't the music just
come back with it and it sort of is a
little out of order but i think 90s and
2000s in some way are like an idealistic
time for like
these like current era teens they're
like wasn't it so great it was the time
before 9 11 yes yeah they don't know it
was the good times 90s rock songs i mean
you had what you had blur in the 90s
right
yeah
that's a great song dude the 90s had
such good stuff i mean metallica in the
90s you got
even with coldplay was amazing when they
first i mean i still like coldplay but
they got a little too electronic nirvana
we even mentioned pearl jam stone temple
pilots this just sound garden chris
cornell the way he could bend his body
these guys dude sound garden dude wow
just so good and and audio slave also
tom morello's got wacky politics but hey
man good music's good music shout out to
dave grohl for good music man doing it
for 30 years man keep it going
oh yeah dude fighters everlong come on
dude it's funny when you know i tweeted
about this and people were ragging on
90s music and i'm like you're crazy bro
like nirvana they were nothing and then
growl joined the band and then they were
nirvana then they created released
nevermind and that that album changed
the world all right some more green lion
says phil murphy in new jersey said
something very similar to hocal last a
few years ago quote if taxes are your
issue we're probably not your state yeah
it was only a few months ago that was a
few months ago that drove me crazy every
time i saw it
taxes are your issues get out of here
long walk says hey tim how do i get my
music to you it's not woke but it's not
anti-woke either i have stuff on youtube
rumble and soundcloud ps dig the new
song and will of the people is a jam too
i don't know yet
but uh carter is going to be running
this new label and all the songs that
we're putting out and he has but one man
who does all the engineering and
production himself
so we just look it really comes out of
this we want to do it
it needs to make money if it doesn't
make money we'll do what we can but
it'll be a small operation to just try
and produce culture and because we enjoy
doing it if these songs actually start
taking off and we do a good job then
we're going to start i think that's the
goal the goal ultimately is to create a
space where people you don't got to be
anti-woke you don't want to be woke we
just want good music you don't got to
bend the needy these weirdos but you
know we're not going to sign we're not
going to sign a rock band that's like
writing songs called like you know
slobbering balls or whatever it's like
you know let me hear the song down with
the straight white males yeah you know
what i mean like there's going to be
some kind of stance dude if someone
releases a song called straight white
i'm into it if it's good song it's
called straight white that'd be hard
it's funny oh yeah
i got a song called uh what is it white
meat hot heat that's pretty nice that
sounds pretty good yeah it's awesome
i want to get you guys in trouble
matt kelly says bought only ever wanted
on itunes it's great i like eve six but
them judging your lyrics is a brave and
oblivious move indeed keep up the fight
the the dude from eve six
uh i don't i don't i don't say he
apologized he said he felt bad about
tweeting that because he responded the
promo saying the lyrics were banal or
something and then i just responded with
like dude i don't care like i'm a huge
fan like when i was a little kid we
would play their covers because they had
like four songs that we were just
playing e6 before the show because it's
it's like two of two of their songs like
they're so good they were so good dude
but but you know like i was i was like
bro you don't gotta like my music and
then he tweeted that he he felt bad
about saying then he took it down and
i'm like right on dude i really i
respect it man look we may disagree on
politics but
they have one of the most iconic songs
of the of the late 90s it's amazing how
like a song when you're young you hear a
song when you're 13 or 15 or something
and it can change your life forever and
then even when you're like 50 and 60 you
still have love for that yeah the
creators of it and the experience that's
funny even without language like my
friends used to burn j-pop and k-pop cds
i didn't understand any of the lyrics
but i still i could play them and feel
like the same
feel connected to them it's just you're
back in your youth and it's beautiful
and maybe i'm having a mid-life crisis
myself but like it's really on air live
yeah no no well my whole career is a
midlife crash
we got a good one here look what logic
says save assange in times square
culture jam i know there are ad rules
but you'll have better ideas than mine
uh than mine friend i know head of rock
alternative at spotify and i'll push
your song let's rock really do
appreciate it and actually that's a
really good idea
so we have two of the biggest billboards
in times square right now but because
it's friday and the run ends in the next
two days there's nothing i can do to get
a save assange message up
but actually that's a really good idea
they wouldn't let me do the twitter
groomer thing because they were like
nope but i'd be willing to bet that i
can get up at billboard in times square
saying free julian assange and i will
absolutely be down to do that and
explore how we get that done because i
think we might be able to even launch
something first thing monday but that
would totally be worth it
julian assange is is look there are
things to criticize him for but what the
government is doing is effectively an
assassination and execution
for 10 years they've they tried to stop
him because he was a powerful voice
challenging the establishment he was a
journalist that that's what he was doing
and now you look at what they're trying
to do to to project veritas it is it is
insanely similar they claimed that
julian assange was like instructing
people to commit crimes this is what
they do you're a journalist and you're
like hey if if you want to leak
something to me like you know talk to
the lawyer and we'll figure out how to
do it the right way then they go he was
instructing them on how to actually
transmit stolen goods that's a crime
espionage act it's bs dude well they
make up the crime first and then find
the evidence to support there right show
me the man i'll show you the crime yeah
yep
great policy
jasper p-jack says matthew 25 35-40 when
i was hungry you gave me something to
eat and when i was thirsty you gave me
something to drink
ian biblical servanthood is proactive to
lift others up forcing someone to serve
is of the devil
i hope that's true i don't like people
adhering to any kind of authority well
you can tell there's versus about like
you know you've heard sayings about like
you can tell a tree by its fruit kind of
thing yes you've i'm sure you've heard
something like that
like actually not really but what do you
mean like if the fruit's sick then the
tree is probably sick yeah the the it's
not a parable but jesus was doing
there's an example of uh he was trying
to eat from a tree and basically it
didn't give him good fruit so he says
may never bear fruit again and then it
wilted in front of them and then he
basically clarified
you can tell a tree by its fruit so the
idea is that if you look at a person's
actions throughout their life if they
serve people
if they
uh display what later would be described
as fruits of the spirit later on by paul
wrote that stuff but the idea is that
you can tell if a person's really
following
the way let's say
uh by
the the fruits of their life like if
they're exercising things like mercy
goodness
hospitality and there's a million
different things but like you could tell
when someone's just full of it and
they're just saying things like you'll
find fake christians all the time
because they say things but they don't
actually live it out or they don't
understand it they may have heard that
right so i always say like covet and the
vaccine stuff and lockdown stuff showed
a lot of people who was who
in terms of you saw words versus actions
playing out i gotta i gotta read this
one from waffle sensei he says my
favorite part of today tim was when some
twitter dude said what's next you're
gonna cover sublime songs or something
he said something like that anyways if
you made a do in time cover of sublime i
personally think you'd break the charts
i just want to point out to everybody
that some of the best memories i have
are being like 18 or 19 and you're at a
party and some random dude grabs the
guitar and then he starts playing bad
fish and then everyone in the house is
drunk singing bad fish those were some
of the best times ever now i'm sure not
everybody experienced something like
that but i'm sure people down in in long
beach and southern california know what
i'm talking about people in chicago know
what i'm talking about that was always a
lot of fun all the stoner dudes new bad
fish
dominic bertolani played bad fish quite
frequently in venice california when i
lived at the math it was it was just so
much fun once like everyone knew the
words and they're singing along and
they're just drunk
dominant covers that's so well too
another good 90s band that's still still
around 311. they're playing out here in
october oh wow yeah 311 is awesome yeah
all mixed up yup i started high school i
started playing the guitar uh uh uh was
it uh i'll be here a while that's in the
name of the song i don't know i don't
know
their first album
um santeria the sublime song when you
hear about singing swimming out past no
no no when he's saying um
he's talking about the break
what's that line when he feels the break
feel the break feel the break feel
the break and i can't live when you're
out in l.a and you surf for the first
time and you go out past the break and
you start to understand that the calm
the stillness of being past the break
and then actually feeling the break it
was like an emo i was tearing they're
actually playing out here too sublime
with rome
they're playing out here like
well yeah because you know bradley is
not around unfortunately but uh the
casino out here is doing a bunch of
shows like uh um blues traveler oh huge
blues traveler fan blues traveler's so
good you know the song hook is just
brilliant writing they took the the the
pop structure and then they mocked it
and it actually turned into something
clever and like it was like pocket belts
they mocked pachelbel's canon or it was
kind of like based off of that and and
then the lyrics are basically how pop
songs were just meant to manipulate you
and it's just brilliant writing like
john popper man yeah he's a great he's
great man dude look i grew up in the 90s
and i know all the all those songs first
album i ever got was americana by the by
the offspring the first song i ever
learned how to play was the kids aren't
all right i also had uh
which album had enter sandman on it
because the black album the black album
and i learned how to play that because
that was the one that like everybody was
always playing and it was easy enough
for me to like play the opening riff
that that that planet
good days man pearl jam versus was my
first album then blues traveler there
that was my second album i got those at
the same time what album was that blues
traveler yep
blues traveler was it just called blues
traveler no it was just called blues
traveler the early 90s huh
yeah
you weren't alive i i was here for some
of the 90s but i don't really remember
it i have to say you were alive oh no
the album was called for the blue show
these youngsters don't know how good
it's back when you tape songs off the
radio like you'd be waiting by the radio
to hear the song and you'd you'd finally
hit record on your tape deck and you'd
get the song that's the only way to be
able to listen to a song again because
otherwise it was just in the ether yet
and then but we had the internet so we
went down burn cd we would we would
download uh songs and it would take like
three hours to get one mp3 and then if
someone called you the download would
collect
you're like
you had a 14-4 modem back in the day we
were downloading anime overnight
episodes
i watched i watched uh the frieza saga
on real player that's right at like 144
p wow and it was like it would play for
five seconds then buffer for like 50
seconds and then play five seconds but
it was like goku he's going super saiyan
it's happening so cool all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and click that link in
the description below if you would
kindly purchase our new single only ever
wanted if everybody who watched this
song bought it we would be like chart
top and it'd be really really big but uh
if you like the song if you want to
support our work if you buy the song and
the song ends up becoming successful
then we're going to be expanding as fast
as fast as we can as rapidly as possible
in launching new music
if it turns out that it's just more of a
hobby project because it doesn't do as
well as we think and
well then we'll just make music that we
like and we'll do it in-house just to
have the music and stuff like that but i
really do think we've got good songs and
we're gonna we're gonna be able to make
something really fantastic here so with
your support we will continue to grow
uh you can follow the show at tim cast
irl you can follow me at tim cast george
you want to shout anything out um no if
you guys just follow me on
instagram and twitter i think on
instagram i'm actually 69.9 k followers
you can change that tonight
i have four new books my poop posts
collections uh issues six through nine
coming out uh they're actually on for
sale you can see that on
twitter and next month i'm releasing a
children's book
uh yeah we made a little children's book
and adorable and we're actually going to
be uh like selling children's cute
children stuff that actually has nothing
to do with me but i'll be announcing
that stuff soon it's very cute very
sweet very innocent has nothing to do
with my usual crap
but it's it's going to be good stuff
right on i'm hannah brimlow i'm a writer
for timcast.com you can check
it every day for your news uh you can
follow me on instagram hannah claire.b
thanks for having me
hello everyone and goodbye i'm ian
crossland great to see you maybe we can
cue up this only ever wanted on uh on
youtube and play this out for you i'm
gonna play
all the homies this one's for you guys
this song changed my life yes we're
gonna see what we can do thank you all
for spending your friday night with us
we do appreciate it i hope you enjoyed
spending this time with george g prime85
you guys can follow me on
twitterreminds.com at sarah patrick's as
well as
uh sourpatch let's stop me i think i'll
just show the video and direct you guys
onto youtube to watch it if you really
want to i think it's just way better to
do yeah um
you know so uh tim cast records there
you go search for that search only ever
wanted official music video shane
cashman of tales from the inverted world
and his wife are the stars
family production over here family
production well it's basically like
we've got a bunch of really talented
people that work here and so we utilized
the resources that we had
and uh we had a fog machine because we
went to guitar center and i was like
they got a fog machine
and then we were putting this video
together
someone mentioned we had a fog machine
and they were like hey we have a fog
machine don't i was like yes
let's bring the fog machine oh yeah
but uh
we filmed this in this really old run
down 1800s barn house
and uh
it's it's creepy
really it's amazing it's cool stuff i
love shane's eyes like he's so emotional
like so much emotion in his eyes yeah
check out the song i mean uh let me
refresh it see how many views we have
now
listen to that
460 317 views and we launched it at
midnight so
looks like we'll end the day 24 hours
with half a million hopefully by next
thursday we'll have gotten enough sales
and views that uh we'll find ourselves
having a successful songer look at this
comment this tim pool sounds like a good
guy maybe he should start a podcast i
appreciate that comment 26 000 thumbs up
we have thousands of comments where the
comments it oh 6 000 comments really do
appreciate all the support you guys
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you